Moin Leute, was geht?
Ups, jetzt habe ich gerade meine Verlängerung untergeschmissen.
Ich muss mal kurz nochmal raus machen.
Äh, mein Headset.
Entknoten.
So.
Der Frasier.
Tja.
Wenn der will, wäre ich sofort am Start.
Aber der will ja nicht.
Ich muss gerade mal meinen Vorschau-Rechner noch anmachen.
Ups.
Ups, die F-Fasse habe ich jetzt hier aufgemacht.
Und hopp.
So, jetzt
Vorschau rechne alles an, wunderbar
Leute, ich sag euch
So, jetzt müssen wir, ups, was jetzt
Meine Güte, Windows hat übrigens
Wieder Random, ist auch geil
Wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich ein bisschen nicht gestreamt hab
stellt Windows hier immer an den Sound-Settings rum.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, warum.
Dann geht immer der Desktop-Sound und der Mikrofon-Sound nicht.
Da muss ich dann immer hier reingehen
und nochmal das Audio-Interface auswählen.
Warum? Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum.
Ich habe weder was abgestöpselt noch sonst was.
Keine Ahnung.
Was Windows da treibt.
so starten wir hier mal das Logitech Ding, dass ich Makros und alles habe
Macros, was die geilen Leute sagen, ist ja nicht Makros, Macros
Macro ist wenn man RTS spielt auch
wenn ich sage Economy macht ja keinen Sinn, so wie man seine Basis baut
so jetzt müssen wir erstmal den linux mini pc einschalten
deskflow starten obs gehen wir nicht auf und sack fullscreen das datt ur dran
zack einschalten und leute was geht bei euch so ich war jetzt glaube ich zwei
wochen nicht an aber heute morgen habe ich mir gedacht wird mal wieder zeit auf
guten jetzt was wir updates machen und ganz wichtig jetzt hier wieder gut naja
letzten paar tage nicht so warum blinkt warum blinkt meine tastatur so komisch
jetzt rum
So, hier sind wir, Linux-Stells, beste.
So, jetzt muss ich erst einmal kurz hier den Bild wegmachen.
Irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist,
ich habe den Eindruck, als wäre mein Monitor heller als sonst.
Hat Nvidia hier irgendwas rumgestellt?
Wo stellt man das jetzt nochmal hier um?
Desktop Color Settings?
Nee.
Doch!
WTF?
Jetzt, wo ich es hier unten auf 1 ziehe, ist wieder normal.
Seht ihr überhaupt den Unterschied?
Wartet mal, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Wenn ich jetzt hier volle Pulle hochdrehe, ist es bei euch überhaupt ein Unterschied?
Nee, gell?
Ihr seht das gar nicht.
Bei mir ist der Bildschirm komplett weiß jetzt.
Nee, ihr seht das gar nicht.
Bei euch kommt das gar nicht an.
Das ist einfach...
Das ist als wäre nix.
Na gut, da ist es ja wahrscheinlich auf der Grafikkarte.
und das Bild wird vorher abgegriffen von OBS.
So.
Irgendwie stand das ungefähr so hier.
Auf diesem Gamma-Wert gerade. Man hat's bloß
nicht gesehen, weil als ich den wieder runtergedreht hab
auf 1.0, sah mein
Display wenigstens wieder normal aus.
Keine Ahnung, was das wieder ist.
So.
Reboot.
Erstmal hier
update machen da update machen das dauert jetzt update all bm yes und hier auch noch mal update
ok winbox kann wieder an installen
und leute was wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt kein c++ flame das halt schon morgen raus
kein c++ flame
Gucken, ob die Kiste noch funktioniert.
Okay, gut.
Rolling Release, by the way.
Übrigens, ich habe es geschafft,
zum ersten Mal,
seit ich meinen neuen Rechner habe,
den kaputt zu machen.
Temporär.
Also ich habe ja seit 2022 den neuen Rechner.
Also neu, der ist jetzt auch schon
dreieinhalb Jahre alt.
Naja, ja doch, fast.
dreieinhalb Jahre alt, übrigens witzigerweise
immer noch saumäßig gut
das hätte es früher auch nicht gegeben, zumindest
irgendwie
ist mir das Ding gefreezed
und dann habe ich eine halbe Minute
gewartet, ich konnte dann nicht mal mehr
Control Alt entfernen und Taskman hätte aufmachen
es ist komplett gefreezed
dann habe ich Reset gedrückt
und dann hing er in VeraCrip Boot Manager
und dann habe ich nochmal
Reset gedrückt
und dann hat Windows gemeint
Recovery Mode, ich kann nicht mehr starten
Da habe ich erst mal doof geguckt und habe gedacht, WTF, was ist da los, wie kann das sein?
Und dann bin ich auf die Idee gekommen, einfach Windows zu booten von der anderen SSD, die noch drin ist.
Ich habe ja zwei SSDs mit Windows drauf.
Und von dort konnte ich ohne Probleme Festplatte drauf zugreifen, mounten und sonst was.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, da muss ja wohl irgendwie der Bootmanager kaputt sein.
und nach längerem Hin und Her probieren
hab ich mir ein
Veracrypt Boot USB Stick
erstellt,
hab den Veracrypt Bootloader
restored und dann ging's.
Es hat aber schon so
1-2 Stunden gedauert, bis ich das gecheckt hab.
Das hatte ich auch noch nicht,
dass der Veracrypt Bootloader kaputt ist.
Das ist wirklich Premiere. Das hatte ich noch nie.
Das hatte ich weder bei TrueCrypt
noch bei Veracrypt, noch sonst irgendwann.
Also in den, keine Ahnung,
naja 20 jahre keine ahnung 20 jahren oder so richtig kam benutze noch nie
wann kam zu köpft raus release day 2004 das habe ich wahrscheinlich seit 2006
oder so also in 20 jahren und ich also ich glaube das ist trotzdem immer noch
ganz gute bilanz wenn man seit seit 20 jahren tool verwendet das hat nur einmal
versagt dann das glaube ich ganz okay und wahrscheinlich lag das noch nicht mal
daran sondern weil windows unglücklich gecrasht ist so jetzt mal hier nochmal
update wie sehen die updates hier aus die updates hier sind fertig jawohl
exzellent
Windows macht gern mal andere Bootloader kaputt, wenn die auf dem selben Drive sind.
Das könnte natürlich auch sein, dass das irgendein Windows-Update war, dann gecrasht ist und beim Rebooten das...
Kann alles sein, weiß nicht.
So.
Reboot.
Chat.
Irgendwie muss ich mir das aliassen,
dass ich beliebig viele Airs
vor das Reboot machen kann und es immer noch
funktioniert. Hat irgendwie einer eine
glorreiche Idee, wie man das Bash
Shell skripten kann?
Irgendein Alias?
Ich glaube, ich habe eine Idee.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das muss man mal ausprobieren.
Afklo. Afklo ist immer noch
hier beste Command.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Guck mal. Wir machen...
Pass mal auf.
Pass mal auf. Hier.
habe ich nicht eine vorschrei für 3 wir machen wir machen mal so was war kopf mal gucken geht
sternchen reboot nee ich glaube nicht aber was wir machen können ist folgendes guck mal wir
können schleife machen wir machen eine schleife und dann machen wir so was hier guck mal so was
so was machen wir in der richtung wir machen von index 1 bis 100 regex geht glaube ich ja
Wir legen einfach alle Sachen an mit Reboot.
So, alias
Dollar Index.
Moment, Chat.
Wie multipliere
ich einen String?
Multiply String Bash.
Wie macht man das? So, repeat.
Alter, was ist das für eine krasse Magic?
WTF?
Was ist?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Was ist das?
Äh
Und hier ist es nur einmal oder was?
Ah, okay, okay, verstehe
Das ist ja wieder geil
Oh, ach du Scheiße, das wird jetzt eklig
Äh
Äh, Chat, Chat, irgendwas habe ich hier doch falsch gemacht
Hier fehlt doch das Done, oder?
WTF?
Was?
Was ist das hier überhaupt?
Das ist doch keine normale Schleife, was ich hier hab, oder?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Oh, Index.
WTF, was ist das für eine Syntax?
Die hab ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Warum hab ich das in meiner Bächertsee?
Ich kenne das hier.
For I in.
Ja, und dann kannst du so sagen, 1 bis 100.
Do Echo Dollar I done.
Das kenne ich.
WTF, was ist das denn?
Aber ich habe es dir in meiner Bash erzählt.
Schon mal gut zu wissen.
So, warte mal hier.
Echo done.
So, jetzt.
Zack.
Also, was wollen wir denn jetzt?
Wir wollen Alias.
Was ist das für eine Syntax?
Jetzt habe ich auch nie gesehen.
Okay, alias.
So, jetzt will ich hier
meist...
Oh, shit, Alter.
Wie funzt denn das?
Moment.
Ah.
Ich check's nicht.
Ach, das muss so
So muss das, okay
Warte mal, Alias
So, da kommt jetzt raus
So, hier muss jetzt Dollar I rein
Dollar I
Das müssen wir aber hier noch
Klammern
Ob das
Ob das Fund ist, was ich hier bastle, keine Ahnung
So, Dollar I
So, da kommt jetzt
Okay, R
Also, beliebig oft, also jetzt 1 bis 100 mal R für Reboot.
Moment, wir kopieren das mal da oben kurz rein, ob das funktioniert.
Und nicht alias, sondern echo davor.
Okay.
Jett, das funktioniert nicht
Ach ne, da muss, Moment, Moment
Hier muss S weiterhin, ne
Ah
Und hier jetzt ein R
Okay, guck mal, guck mal
Pog
Echo
Boot
Ha, guck mal
Und schon haben wir, schon haben wir 100 Mal
Reboot
Obviously
So
Und jetzt
Und jetzt müssen wir das nochmal
Ich glaube jetzt müssen wir das nochmal
Klammer
Ich echo es nochmal
Funktioniert immer noch
So und jetzt sagen wir
Alias
Reboot
Wie funktioniert das jetzt
Gleich
Reboot
Okay
Es funzt, Leute
Guck mal, es funktioniert
Ist das nicht krasse Magic hier wieder?
Shell-Stells, Alter
WTF
Okay
Ganz
Das geht bestimmt auch
Das geht bestimmt auch schöner
Wie das aussieht
BTF
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der sich das anguckt
Und sagt, obviously
Ah, alles klar, jetzt weiß ich sofort, was passiert
Okay, gucken wir mal
So, schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert
Reboot
Kunst
Easy
Easy kann man dazu nur sagen
Also eindeutig ist das
Achso, Moment, ich hab die, ich hab's nicht laut
Moment, jetzt ist der Sound zu laut
Äh
Nein, WTF
Hallo
Ich brauch ein bisschen was.
Danke, Gildas.
Ich brauch die Mario-Karten-Musik, Leute.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Excellent.
Ach so.
Haha, jetzt muss ich ja wieder die Tastatur anstöpseln.
Warum? Warum was?
Warum, warum?
Für Regex?
Ja, wer will's denn?
Alias mit Regex?
Gibt es sowas?
Gibt es in Regex?
Äh, das geht?
Das geht?
Wirklich?
Nee, oder?
Das funktioniert.
Da muss, das muss ja hier vorne, muss ja das neue Kommando sein.
Nee, nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Du kannst in Bash sogar irgendwie Regex machen, aber nur um Variableninhalte zu checken und sowas.
Jetzt nicht für Aliasse.
Man muss ja quasi ein neues Kommando anlegen, was so heißt wie der Befehl.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das mit dem Regex funktioniert.
Aber wir können ja mal, pass mal auf, wir fragen jetzt mal KI, ob die versteht.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Was zum Teufel habe ich hier gerade geöffnet?
Chat, WTF?
Was ist das? Ich wollte Firefox starten.
The fuck?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall
etwas älter aus.
Ah, hier. Das ist das
Fluid Interface Designer
von 1998.
Alles klar, so sieht es auch aus.
Du findest...
Ach, deswegen habe ich mich vertippt.
Warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Wozu ist das gut? Warum ist das da?
Okay, warte mal
Jetzt gucken wir mal
Jetzt lassen wir uns mal erklären
Von
Okay, von ChatGPT
Von China-Chinesen-Model
Und von Google
Lassen wir uns das jetzt mal erklären
Was macht das?
So
Copy
Was macht das?
KI-Modus
Okay, Google, auf geht's
Dieser Befehl ist ein kleiner Streich für die Kommandozeile
Ein Streich
Debate sozusagen
Du nutzt momentan das hier statt Cache Default
Was ist das?
A focused launcher for your desktop
Achso, da kann man einfach
Rofi benutzen, oder?
Warum ist das besser?
Okay, sieht ein bisschen so aus
Ich benutze das KDE, die fall
gut ist
Okay, also, dieser Befehl ist ein kleiner
Streich für die, guck mal, das erstellt 100
verschiedene Alias für den Befehl Reboot
Das ist korrekt, ja
Okay, immerhin
Es ist soweit verständlich, dass die KI
Das erklären kann
Okay, kann man das
Eleganter
Lösen
Anstatt 100 mal
Ich frage einfach nur, kann man das eleganter lösen
Ja, das geht
Aha
Das funzt
Hä?
Ne, das funzt nicht
So, das hier könnte
Das hier könnte funktionieren
Vor I in du alias
Er
Ein
Hä?
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Guck mal.
Der macht 100 mal die Schleife, um dann in jedem Schleifendurchlauf 1 bis das Doppelt anzulegen.
Hä?
Aber das heißt doch im Endeffekt, wir können darauf verzichten.
Und das hier sollte dann funktionieren.
schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Aber ich hab da so meine Zweifel.
Okay, das hat funktioniert.
Machen wir mal
B-Boot.
Nee, funktioniert nicht.
Ah, siehste hier.
Siehste, Blödsinn.
Also hier die
Sache von's nicht, was der da
treibt.
Das ist Mist, was die Google KI ausspuckt.
Okay.
Dieser Code erstellt...
Okay, fragen wir den ja auch mal.
Kann man das eleganter lösen?
Fragezeichen.
So.
Also ChatGPT checkt es auch.
Wichtig, nicht harmlos.
Das Skript ist im Grunde ein kleiner Spaß oder Troll.
Ist das so?
Kann man das eleganter lösen?
Okay, was sagt die China...
Was?
Die China-Chinesen-KI ist überlastet.
Was die Stongs machen, die sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen...
Die sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen.
Wartet mal, ich gucke mir mal meine Stonks gerade an.
Lasst mich mal kurz reingucken.
Markets closed, ja.
Stonks sind jetzt eigentlich so mit auf dem höchsten Stand wie bisher.
Ich habe World ETF.
World ETF und so eine Art Tagesgeld.
Aber das Hauptsächliche habe ich im World ETF.
Okay.
Das thinkt und hört nur nicht auf zu thinken.
Also was sagt der Chat-GPT dazu?
Kann man das elegant...
Das geht deutlich eleganter und auch lesbarer.
Okay.
Saubere Variante.
Äh, findet ihr das lesbarer und sauberer?
Sequence?
Der macht wieder den gleichen Fehler wie Google.
Guck mal, der legt pro Schleifendurchlauf.
Oh, Schleifen durchlaufen.
Legt der hier wieder
alles neu an?
Okay, wir checken mal,
ob das funktioniert.
Also so advanced,
dass sogar die KI überfordert ist.
Machen wir jetzt
B-Boot.
Okay, das ist von uns anscheinend.
Ne, der hat nur eins angelegt.
Ah, Moment.
Ich glaube, das ist doch nicht so blöd, was die KI macht.
Ich check's nur nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ich check nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Beboot.
Okay, das funktioniert, was die KI da macht.
Checken tue ich es allerdings nicht.
Was macht denn hier dieses Sequence?
Das ist doch bei jedem Schleifendurchlauf neu.
Ach, nee.
Das erzeugt immer die Anzahl vom Schleifendurchlauf von Zeichen.
Ach, okay, okay, okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, das macht doch Sinn, was die KI ausgespuckt hat.
Aber ich weiß, naja, es ist beides nicht wirklich gut lesbar, oder?
ich bleibe bei meinem manuell zusammengewurschteten.
Oh, das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Das finde ich sogar relativ
Das ist, bist du da selbst drauf gekommen
Oder hast du auch hier eine KI gefragt
Das finde ich eine sehr clevere Lösung
Ein Händler
Der aufgerufen wird
Wenn man ein Kommando eingibt
Dass es nicht gibt
Wobei dann Autocomplete
Nicht funktioniert, oder
Dann funktioniert Autocomplete nicht
Bei meinen Sachen funktioniert ja Autocomplete
Ich kann RR eingeben und dann autocomplete der mir RR-Reboot.
Und das muss ja sein.
Ich meine, ich will ja hier RR eingeben können und dann autocomplete.
Ne, ne.
Minimalistisch und verständlich.
Unschlüssig, ob das jetzt irgendwie verständlicher ist.
Was?
Das eigentliche Problem ist nicht die Eleganz, sondern die Idee.
WeChat GPT.
Was hast du für Probleme mit Reboot?
100 Alias für Reboot sind schwer zu debuggen, potenziell gefährlich, unnötig. Warum?
Bessere Alternative, funktional gedacht.
Wenn es hier darum geht, Tippfehler, darum geht es mir nicht.
mein eigentliches ziel war mein eigentliches ziel war dass ich auch reboot eingeben kann oder
beliebt mit mit beliebig vielen recht in your face dankeschön für den sub dann ist der ansatz
mit 100 Alias eigentlich die... Was? Warum?
Okay, mit...
Die hat recht. Das ist Mist, was ich geschrieben hab.
Nicht mit beliebig vielen. Okay.
Aber da bin ich mal gespannt, was es für ein Beispiel
hat für beliebig viele.
Mit 101
eher geht das nicht. Okay.
Was du willst, ist ein Muster. Kein fester Satz im Namen.
Elegante
Lösung funktioniert statt Aliases.
Hä?
Aha.
Bash Command Not Found Hook.
Ja, das hat der Andreas3124
auch gerade geschrieben.
Aber, aber
damit geht doch
damit geht kein Auto
Komplit.
Optional sicherer.
Okay.
Das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Neat Twitch. Danke schön für den Sub.
So. Moment.
Ähm.
Wir machen jetzt B-Boot.
Okay. B-Boot.
Das Auto Komplit geht
damit nicht.
damit geht
Autocomplete nichts.
Also bis jetzt
hat mir die KI noch nichts besseres
vorgeschlagen.
Das hier check ich schon mal gar nicht.
Wie das hier
wie das
funktionieren soll.
Aber wir können das einfach mal kurz
mit B-Boot
Das check ich nicht
Da fehlt ein R nach dem Command-Not-Found-Händler
Ah
Hat da
Hab ich falsch Copy-Pasted
Oder hat die KI Mist gemacht
Ja
Der hat Mist gemacht
Aber Funds trotzdem nicht
Kein Auto-Complete
KI macht Mist, wer hätte das gedacht
Okay, so
Okay, die KI weiß, was ich eigentlich will
Genau, das ist der Haken an der Lösung
Ja, genau, ja, schön
Greift erst nach dem Enter
Was du eigentlich willst
Tricky, weil Bash nur konkrete Kommandos kennt
Kein Regalist
Ja, okay, aber mal ganz ehrlich
Chat, was hast du denn gegen meine Lösung
Lösung, Completions selber beibringen
Wenn man Reboot
WTF, warum nicht einfach meins
Bessere Lösung, Readline Keybinding
Wirklich elegant
Ähm
Was bin ich sehend
WTF, was ist das
Ctrl M
Was
Okay, das ist natürlich eine sehr wirklich elegante Lösung.
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass die wirklich elegant aussieht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, ja.
Pragmatic Hack funktioniert bloß simpel.
Reboot alias Komite.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich gebe mich mit 1 bis 100 R zufrieden.
Okay.
Bei 1 bis 100
stimmt er mit mir überein.
Meine Lösung ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Als du es noch etwas
nerdiger haben willst.
Was?
Ah!
Das finde ich gar nicht mal so blöd.
Einfach
anhängen, anstatt irgendwelche
Magic.
Das...
Naja.
Gut, so wirklich viel schlauer sind wir auch nicht.
Was sagt denn die China-Chinesen?
Was sagt denn die China-Chinesen-KI?
Kann man das eleganter lösen?
Ja, absolut.
Der ursprüngliche Code ist ein klassisch...
Ah, classic.
Heck, er nutzt einen Trick mit Leerzeichen und Suchenersetzen.
Okay, hier sind drei deutlich elegantere Lösungen von der einfachen Optimierung bis zur Profi...
Oh, jetzt auf die Profilösung bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt.
Okay, ja.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Das finde ich tatsächlich auch schöner als mein komisches Gebastel da.
Einzeiler mit Printf ohne den Leerzeichen-Trick.
Okay, hatten wir auch schon. Ist auch okay.
Ich bleibe trotzdem bei meinen.
Die ultimative elegante Lösung.
Funktion statt 100 Aliase.
Warum denken die eigentlich, dass es...
Heißt es jetzt eigentlich Command Not Found Handle?
Oder... Ah ne, es heißt Command Not Found Handle
Nicht Command Not Found Handler
Command Not Found Handle vs. Handler
Was?
Ja, wie jetzt?
Ne, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
ZSH
ist es command not found händler in der bash ist es command not found händler
man kann es auch noch komplizierter machen
Warum das die beste...
Aber mit
Kunst kein
Autokom
Lied.
So, Chat, ich bleib
bei meiner Variante, um
Reboot tippen zu können.
Was hat's für Probleme?
dann führen wir es dann nochmal aus bis es funktioniert
ja erstmal ordentlich die hartz-car-preise in die höhe treiben für reboot
Also Chat, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich heute on bin.
Wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Aufwachen, streamen, mal gucken.
Mir ging es wieder recht schlecht die letzten Tage.
Mal gucken, wie es läuft.
So, schauen wir mal, was die KI jetzt sagt.
Okay, so, kleiner Hack.
Du hast absolut recht, sehr gute Beobachtung.
command not found wieso eigentlich das ist das ist kein rage alias ich tippe
einfach nur gerne reboot ein mit mehreren russ ist ein wenn du also tippen willst
und dann tab drücken möchtest damit die shell kommst du um echte alias nicht
herum ja gut so kann man das machen die ki behauptet dass ja keine ahnung was
die sich da überlegt.
So, okay.
Chat.
Also das wäre...
Da stimme ich der KI sogar zu.
Das hier wäre schon die elegantere Lösung
als meins.
Also muss man ehrlich auch mal sagen.
Also das ist schon schöner und lesbarer
als meins.
Aber ich behalte meins, weil das nicht KI gestrickt ist,
sondern manuell meinem Kopf entsprungen ist.
Ach, was macht eigentlich die Verfügbarkeit von GitHub so?
Die wird immer schlechter, Alter.
93 Inzidenz in den letzten 90 Tagen.
Ey, mit der Verfügbarkeit hätte ich auf der Arbeit schon jeglichen Bonus gestrichen bekommen.
Und nicht nur ich, sondern mein gesamtes Team.
Also nicht mein Team, das Team, in dem ich bin.
Nicht dieses...
Wir würden alle keinen Bonus mehr kriegen
bei der Verfügbarkeit.
Es dauert nicht mehr lang,
da ist sie bei 6-7, ja.
Wobei 6-7 ist ja auch schon wieder out.
Also, du kannst von ausgehen,
sobald solche Sachen
bei so Boomern wie uns angekommen sind,
dann sind sie bei der eigentlichen Gen-Alpha
schon wieder out.
sobald im prinzip kann man sich sobald wir davon hören und es selbst benutzen
und bescheid wissen ist es wieder out das ist das ist schon quasi davor wieder out
deswegen ist einfach die ultimative art und weise einfach in twitch e mails reden das
ist nie out aus der twitch macht irgendwann mal dicht was wir mal nicht hoffen wollen
outdated, overrated, she baited
übrigens
gestern neue Katze gefunden, guckt mal hier
also mit gefunden meine ich über den Weg gelaufen
guckt mal hier
dicke, langhaarige Katze
gefunden gestern
die lag da einfach so unter einem Busch, als ich vorbeigelaufen bin
da bin ich immer hin und da haben wir 5 Minuten gestreichelt
ist doch niedlich, oder?
Ganz schön eine zottelige Katze ist das.
Die hat lange Haare.
Und wenn du die gestreichelt hast,
hast du ganz viele
Knoten und
Dreck. Also, die
müsstest du eigentlich regelmäßig kämmen.
Spazierende Katze.
Ja, ich halt auch immer
ausschaue.
Ich kenn fast alle Katzen schon.
Guck mal.
Die kommt ja bei mir regelmäßig vorbei hier.
die hier
die kommt er jeden Tag vorbei lässt sich füttern
und wenig und wenig auch regelmäßig sehe ist
wenig auch regelmäßig sie hier
ist um
sich auch regelmäßig
und wo ist denn die andere
Den sehe ich auch regelmäßig.
Das ist Mario Galaxy Musik, oder?
Ja.
Also.
Das ist Mario Kart Musik, aber eigentlich ist Mario Galaxy Musik.
Hat jemand den Mario Galaxy Film geguckt?
Also ins Kino gehe ich dafür nicht.
Aber der erste, also nicht der allererste Mario Film, der letzte animierte Mario Film, der war ja auch ganz okay.
Den werde ich mir irgendwann mal
im Streaming angucken.
Chat, Chat, ich habe übrigens
einen neuen, erfolgreichsten,
das habe ich gar nicht gedacht,
neuen, erfolgreichsten
Twitter-Posts gehabt
die letzten Tage. Guck mal, das hier.
Hier.
Ich habe
gepostet,
dass ich mit Bonuszahlung
Ja, dass ich mit
Bonuszahlung
9000 Euro hab
überwiesen bekommen.
Und das haben
Leute geliked und 115
Leute kommentiert. So viel hatte ich
noch nie.
Muss man vielleicht öfters
irgendwelche...
Das ist... Ich glaube,
das grenzt fast schon ein bisschen an
Ragebait, oder?
Wobei es kein Bait ist.
Das grenzt,
das ist aber so ein typisches
Bait-Kommentar, wo dann auch
viele Leute drauf einsteigen, so nach
dem Motto, ja, ja, und bei mir
ist es so, und ja, und in der
Altenpflege ist es so, und hier und da.
Dabei war das jetzt
komplett unabhängig
davon.
Man muss dazu sagen, ich krieg das ja auch nicht jeden Monat.
Das war jetzt mit
Bonuszahlung. Bei uns ist es ja so,
man kriegt einmal im Jahr
eine große Bonuszahlung
und jeden Monat
eine Teilbonuszahlung.
Das ist super kompliziert. Das muss ich euch
jetzt nicht erklären, wie das genau funktioniert.
Aber ich krieg jeden Monat einen kleinen
Bonus und einmal im Jahr einen großen Bonus.
so.
Und
das war halt im April soweit.
Deswegen waren es
jetzt trotz Teilzeit und
gar nicht so viel Rufbereitschaft
war das halt
so viel.
Und wisst ihr,
was das Schlimmste ist?
Man müsste sich das
mal angucken, was das Ganze
Brutto wäre.
Das wären wahrscheinlich
17k oder so brutto.
Und davon geht die Hälfte weg.
Was meint ihr denn?
Ach so, der Mario Galaxy Film.
Ja.
Ja, bei den Amis ist das ja nix.
Die Amis verdienen das ja wirklich im Monat, jeden Monat.
Aber, dafür hast du bei den Amis das Problem,
Wenn du ins Krankenhaus musst, bist du die halt auch relativ schnell wieder los.
Da gab es noch diese Story von, ich weiß nicht, ob die stimmt,
aber ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass die stimmt, weil Kekona...
Da gab es noch dieses... Wo habe ich denn meinen Kekona-E-Mode?
Da gab es noch diese Story von, Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt, kommt ins Krankenhaus,
wird wieder aufgepäppelt, ist soweit wieder fit, wird entlassen,
bekommt die Rechnung vom Krankenhaus,
kriegt zweiten Herzinfarkt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das
ausgedacht ist oder ob das stimmt,
aber das kann ich
mir schon durchaus vorstellen.
Was meint ihr, wie teuer es ist?
Das ist jetzt eher eine Frage, ne?
Was meint ihr, wie teuer das ist,
wenn man sich für Herzinfarkt
Behandlung im Krankenhaus,
ich meine Herzinfarkt Behandlung ist ja im Prinzip,
du musst ins Krankenhaus, du musst da eine Weile liegen,
du kriegst
Blutverdünnungssachen. Du kriegst vielleicht
irgendwie so ein Ding ins Herz
per Katheter eingeschoben, was das
offen hält und sowas.
Da bist du doch in den USA.
Keine Ahnung, wie viel los.
120.000 Euro oder so.
Wenn du einen guten Job hast,
ja, das ist das,
wäre sinnvoll, ja.
das ist halt mega teuer
die haben extra armbänder dass du nicht das heißt wenn wenn jemand den
rettungswagen ruft du hast du eine armband lassen sie sich liegen oder was
wirklich
ja gut es wurde habe ich nicht also wie gesagt so ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen dass diese geschichte stimmt ja so jetzt gehen wir mal hier wieder
rüber und eine eine entspannungsrunde aske aquarium
Ja Leute, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was.
Warum ich die letzten zwei Wochen nicht gestreamt habe.
Sibaro hat das Archiv... Ach, war das kaputt?
Siehst du, das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Nice, Sibaro. Excellent.
Sehr schön.
Woher weißt du...
Moment, woher weißt du, dass es der Sibaro war?
Ach, das läuft immer noch auf seinem Server, ne?
Das heißt, der Sebarro hat sich mal wieder gemeldet.
Was macht er denn so?
Der Cute-Mod persönlich.
Achso.
Aber du weißt ja,
der AF-Programmer ist schon wieder
voll informiert hier.
Der ist besser informiert, was mit meinem Archiv passiert, als wenn man beim Discord abgeht, als ich.
Ist aber auch gut so.
Ja, ich erzähl euch jetzt mal, warum ich die letzten zwei Wochen nicht gestreamt hab, zumindest so grob.
Mir ging's nicht so gut, ich bin grad dabei, ein bisschen meine Pillen zu reduzieren, die ich nehme.
Und vielleicht hab ich das ein bisschen schnell gemacht, weiß ich nicht.
zumindest habe ich mir wieder krass Gedanken um gesundheitliche Themen gemacht und habe
mich voll reingesteigert und da war es mir nicht nach striemen. So sieht es aus. Deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich lasse mal lieber aus, bevor ich dann hier sitze und gar nichts gescheites auf die
reihe krieg was ich mir dafür eine scheiße immer ausdenke das echter wahnsinn ja
So, dann gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Also ein Beispiel, dass ihr versteht, was ich mir teilweise für einen Schwachsinn ausdenke.
Ich habe mir so hier...
Ja, es geht mir ja im Prinzip im Durchschnitt schon viel, viel besser als noch vor einem halben Jahr oder einem Dreivierteljahr.
Ich habe letztens hier so unten an meine Jawline, wie man das ja jetzt nennt, gegriffen.
Also da, wo halt der Knochen ist.
Nee, beim Kinn halt, der Knochen.
Vom Kiefer, Kieferknochen.
Hab ich so drangegriffen und hab gedacht, oh, da ist ein Knubbel.
Also du musst schon extrem genau fühlen, dass du überhaupt irgendwas merkst.
ich nehme was anderes
das habe ich mir aber tatsächlich auch schon
haben wir auch schon drüber geredet, ob man das vielleicht
als Alternative mal ausprobiert
da muss ich schon super genau
hinfühlen, wahrscheinlich ist es
ein Stück vom Muskel oder
irgendwie irgendwas, nix nix
und da habe ich
einen halben Tag dran rumgefühlt und gemacht
und hab mich übelst reingesteigert,
das muss ein Tumor sein.
Total hängen geblieben, Alter.
Total hängen geblieben.
Und da war ich schon kurz davor.
Naja, so ganz kleine Sachen
siehst du ja da auch nicht drauf.
Naja, zumindest hab ich mich voll
reingesteigert wieder.
Hab gedacht, das muss ein Tumor sein.
Also, wir reden hier über eine Sache,
die ist, keine Ahnung,
ein Millimeter groß
wenn überhaupt, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine Hautfalte
oder so, whatever.
Das merkst du
normalerweise gar nicht.
Du musst es wirklich schon millimeterweise
abtasten, dass du irgendwas merkst.
Zumindest habe ich mich wieder
drüber aufgeregt,
das muss ein Tumor sein.
Und dann habe ich mich
dabei ertappt, dass ich schon wieder
bei meiner Ärztin nach einem Termin
geguckt habe. Und da habe ich mich dran
erinnert, was mein
Psychologe mal gesagt hat.
Und zwar, dass es das auf Dauer nicht besser macht. Dieses wegen jenem Furz zum Arzt rennen und sich bestätigen lassen, dass nichts ist. Und dann habe ich das wieder abgebrochen und habe mir keinen Termin geholt.
Auch wenn mir das echt schwer fällt
Weil ich will dann immer so diese Bestätigung haben
Ach, es ist doch gar nichts Schlimmes
Aber ich meine, das ist jetzt so abgedreht
Was ich mir da ausgedacht habe wieder
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das nicht mal
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das nicht mal ertasten
So nicht sagen, dass das
Naja
Ja, und übrigens, weißt du, was noch besser ist?
Was ja noch viel besser ist
Weil du es hier gesagt hast, du hast einen Ganzkörper-MRT
machen lassen. Ich hatte ja auch
einen MRT vom ganzen Kopf.
Und man hat nichts drauf gesehen.
Also kann.
Und das ist keine Ahnung.
Das ist, äh,
vielleicht sechs Monate auch her.
Man hat nichts drauf gesehen.
Was soll das sein?
Weil das hilft mir nicht.
Weil ich finde
trotzdem irgendwas. Ich finde immer,
irgendwas, was mich aufregt. Das ist ja das Schlimme.
Aber ich werde mich
jetzt an das halten, was der Psychologe gesagt hat.
Ich mache jetzt erstmal keinen Termin
beim Arzt, weil ich kann ja nicht wegen jedem
kleinen Furz immer
da hinrennen, mich wahnsinnig
aufregen
und mir es dann immer bestätigen lassen,
dass nichts ist, weil so lernt man ja
auch nicht, mit ein bisschen Unsicherheit
leben zu können. Und da kommt es ja
letztendlich drauf an. Man muss gucken, dass man mit ein bisschen
Unsicherheit klarkommt.
wobei das ja noch nicht mal wirklich unsicherheiten den sie das einfach
komplett an den haaren herbeigezogen wahrscheinlich habe ich das an der
stelle schon keine ahnung zehn jahre oder so hat es aber nie gemerkt naja
zumindest das in kombination mit ich versuche meine pillen ein bisschen zu
reduzieren war vielleicht war vielleicht so blöd
Ich nehme ja zwei verschiedene Sorten.
Das da nehme ich nicht.
Ich nehme, äh...
Gut, dass du nicht Medizin steht.
Da werden echt viele Leute im Laufe des Studiums...
Ja, das würde ich nicht aushalten.
Das würde ich nicht aushalten.
Ich kriege ja schon immer komplette Zustände,
wenn ich mal nach irgendwas google oder so.
Das hat mir mein Psychologe auch gesagt.
Ich soll endlich aufhören,
nach Krankheitssachen zu googeln.
Weil du findest immer irgendwas.
Ja, so nach dem Motto Kopfschmerzen.
Gehirntumor.
Ja, also Google ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Falls einer von euch auch so Probleme hat.
Ohne Mist.
Das mache ich auch nicht mehr.
Das mache ich auch nicht mehr. Also ich hatte ja jetzt, ich hatte ganz lang super Blutdruck. Also seit ich angefangen habe Sport zu machen und so super. Also ich habe ja früher, habe ich so ganz kleine Dosierung Blutdruck Tabletten genommen. Die habe ich dann gar nicht mehr gebraucht, seit ich regelmäßig angefangen habe Sport zu machen und abgenommen habe. War alles super, alles top.
Ja, und seit ich jetzt angefangen habe, mich da so reinzusteigern in diesen Scheiß, habe ich am Anfang, habe ich mir jeden Tag fünfmal Blutdruck gemessen und der war natürlich nicht sonderlich gut. Ja, da hatte ich dann irgendwie 140, 145 oder irgendwie sowas und umso mehr ich mich da reingesteigert habe, umso schlechter ist das Ganze auch geworden.
früher hatte ich keine ahnung 108 80 oder irgendwie sowas also alles top und seit ich
angefangen habe mich so reinzusteigen und irgendwann hat mir auch mal psychologe gesagt
ich soll einfach kein blutdruck mehr messen wenn wirklich irgendwas schlimmes ist dann merke ich
das schon ich muss mir nicht jeden tag drei vier fünf mal blutdruck messen ich weiß mir einfach
gar kein blutdruck jedes mal wenn ich zu meinem doktor gehe messen die da kurz blutdruck die
sagen ein bisschen zu hoch aber aufregung und alles und ist okay ja ich
weiß ich weiß was ich auch nicht mehr mache ist ich ziehe auch nicht mehr
meine meine fitness pur an und puls zu kontrollieren und so was das ist alles
übelster stress die lua dankeschön dankeschön für den
zap du glaubst es nicht es haben total viele leute mir hat mir hat jemand ich
war ja sogar mal in der ambulanz in der psychiatrie das habe ich glaube ich
schon mal im stream erzählt letztes jahr irgendwann im august oder so als es mir
so schlecht ging und man auch mal gucken wollten wegen medikamenten und so was
da bin ich in die ambulante sprechstunde bei uns hier in der in frankfurt in die
psychiatrie gegangen da hatte ich ja übelst krass schiss
davor weil ich gedacht habe die behalten mich gleich da und sperren mich ein so
nach dem motto was aber auch schwachsinn ist aber dank für den sub was halt
totaler Blödsinn ist. Aber man weiß ja nicht,
man kennt das ja nur so aus dem Fernsehen.
So, aber da bin ich
hingegangen und es war vollkommen
fein, überhaupt keine Probleme.
Die haben auch gesagt, sie behalten
mich nicht hier gegen meinen Willen und sonst was.
Weil jetzt muss ich mir überhaupt
keine Gedanken machen.
Und die
haben mir dann zwei Sachen aufgeschrieben
und seitdem ist auch wirklich besser.
Seitdem ist besser.
ich habe ich habe eine sache für morgens das ist ja das ist sehr traurig heißt
dass das ist so ein standardding was man nimmt bei so so so angstzuständen und
dann habe ich abends eine halbe noch was anderes was ein bisschen beruhigt und
die die billigkeit also die abend also morgens habe ich schon um eine halbe
reduziert und abends
habe ich auch ein bisschen weiter
reduziert, weil ich will nicht, es reicht
ja auch, ja.
Ja, am Anfang ist es ein bisschen,
am Anfang ist es ein bisschen stressig,
ja, da
wirst du teilweise ein bisschen nervös
davon und alles.
Das stimmt,
aber das hat sich bei dir wahrscheinlich auch
nach den ersten drei, vier Wochen wieder gelegt,
ne, denke ich mal.
Man muss scharfen Stress zu reden.
Ja, das hilft tatsächlich.
Also eine Sache, die bei mir mehr hilft
oder besser hilft.
Du hast dich zu gut gefühlt.
Okay, das hatte ich nicht.
Ich war übelst nervös am Anfang.
Nee, nee.
Ich habe aber so gut wie keine Nebenwirkungen
von dem ganzen Scheiß, ja. Ich hab also
nix, nix. Ich nehm aber auch nicht so viel.
Ähm, also, also
was bei mir wirklich gut hilft, ist
ähm
Können wir jetzt mal ein bisschen drüber. Äh, was
man, was man mir wirklich besser hilft,
fast besser hilft als alle Tabletten,
ist, ähm
ja, das ist,
das ist ja, irgendwas stimmt nicht, ist ja auch
so typischer Gedanke, den man da hat. Bei allem
hat man den, ja.
Was bei mir wirklich besser hilft,
als alle Tabletten, ist regelmäßig bewegen.
Wenn ich am Tag
45 Minuten gerannt bin,
geht's mir den restlichen Tag
besser, wie ich nehme
irgendeine Tablette zur Beruhigung.
Ja, ja, ja, das
kenne ich. Aber, wie gesagt,
ich versuche das mal zu beschreiben.
für Leute, die sowas noch nicht hatten.
Also wenn man eine Angststörung hat,
wobei korrekterweise nennt man das ja heute Angsterkrankung,
weil sich irgendjemand diskriminiert gefühlt hat wegen Störung.
Oder wie nennt man das heute ganz allgemein?
Neurodivergent oder irgendwie sowas.
Angststörung ist, glaube ich, das,
was sich die meisten Leute vorstellen können.
Nur mal so zum Beschreiben.
Kennt ihr, also weil viele Leute,
die sowas noch nicht hatten.
Sekunde.
So, was ich jetzt sagen wollte.
Also, weil viele Leute, die sowas noch nicht hatten,
Die denken sich, ah ja, da muss man mal zwei, drei Wochen ein bisschen die Zähne zusammenbeißen und durch und dann ist auch wieder gut.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das habe ich am Anfang auch gedacht, so ey, das geht doch auch schon wieder weg und irgendwie, das ist aber nicht so.
Ihr müsst euch das vorstellen, kennt ihr, kennt ihr Traktor Pulling?
Das ist so ein komischer Sport
Da stehen die Amis total drauf
Moment, ich zeige euch das mal
Dann werdet ihr vielleicht verstehen
Worauf ich raus will, ja
So, Traktor Pulling
So
Das ist so eine komische
Ich nenne es mal Sportart
Warst du da vorhin Burnout? Ne
Das ist so eine Sportart, wo es darum geht
mit besonders viel Aufwand und besonders viel Kraft, ja,
mit besonders viel Kraft so einen Anhänger zu ziehen, ja,
und der Anhänger, ihr seht ja das hier,
der Anhänger, der liegt auf dem Boden und schleift immer mehr Erde mit.
Das heißt, je stärker du dran ziehst, umso mehr staut sich das auf
und irgendwann geht es nicht mehr weiter.
so und so ungefähr könnt ihr euch das bei einer angststörung vorstellen dieses augen zu und durch
ist wie das also ihr braucht super viel kraft für dieses augen zu und durch und es wird nicht
besser trotz augen zu und durch so könnt ihr euch das vorstellen also ihr denkt das muss doch jetzt
besser werden das muss doch jetzt besser werden was mache ich mir schon wieder gelang es kann
Kann doch nicht sein. Und in Wirklichkeit,
was damit passiert ist,
es staut sich immer
mehr in eurem Traktor auf.
Und irgendwann,
irgendwann wisst ihr gar nicht mehr, was ihr machen sollt.
Ja, dann trotz aller
Kraft,
macht ihr euch
den ganzen Tag nur noch Gedanken.
So kann man sich das ungefähr
vorstellen,
für jemanden, der sowas noch nicht hatte.
Wie Traktor-Pulling im Kopf.
Ja.
Und das Schlimme ist dann daran, irgendwann hörst du halt auch damit nicht auf, dir Gedanken zu machen und du machst dir dann Gedanken über das Gedanken machen.
Und irgendwann machst du dir dann gar keine Gedanken mehr über konkrete Dinge, sondern du machst dir Gedanken davor, dass du wieder dir Gedanken machst.
Ja und sowas. Das ist halt richtig krass hängen geblieben.
und das kann man
also wie gesagt, ich finde dieses Beispiel
mit dem Traktor Pulling, kann man sich das wirklich
bildlich mal vorstellen, das kann man sich
nicht, das kann man sich wirklich schwer vorstellen, wenn man
das noch nicht hatte und
was halt auch nicht geht
ist, oder was ich früher
auch gedacht habe, als ich sowas noch nicht hatte
ist
ja ja, klar
diese ganzen Angst, das ändert auch was
im Kopf, klar, deswegen
helfen diese Tabletten ja auch
die sorgen dann dafür, dass du mehr
Serotonin hast und Gedöns und andere
Sachen gebildet werden und sowas.
Deswegen hilft der Kram ja auch.
Zumindest, was ich mir früher auch gedacht
habe, ist,
naja,
zum Beispiel, wenn sich
jemand super krasse Gedanken macht,
irgendeine Krankheit zu haben.
Ich habe
XY.
Oder einfach, ist auch egal, was es ist.
Dann, warum denkt man sich da nicht einfach, ja, mal zwei Wochen abwarten und dann gucken, ob es immer noch da ist.
Oder, hey, es kann doch eigentlich nichts sein, ich war doch erst beim Arzt.
So, warum denkt man sich das nicht und hakt es dann ab?
Das klappt nicht mit dem Abhaken.
Es ist ein Unterschied zwischen, man weiß eigentlich, rational betrachtet, dass es sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich ist.
Aber es gibt noch so einen kleinen Restzweifel im Kopf, der dich fertig macht.
Ja, du bist dir eigentlich zu 95% sicher, es ist Blödsinn, was du dir denkst.
Aber diese 5% Restzweifel, die du im Kopf hast, die bläst du auf zu viel wichtiger als 95%.
Also viel wichtiger als die rationalen 95%.
Das ist dann eher 50-50 im Kopf.
So 50%, obwohl es vielleicht nur von rational betrachtet nur 5% wirklich was sein könnte, machst du daraus 50% und hast dann quasi die einen 50% im Kopf, die sagen, ey, wird schon nix sein und die anderen 50%, die so das Negative maßlos überbewerten.
und, ähm,
dann hast du dann immer so ein permanentes Battle
im Kopf, zwischen es ist nix und es
ist was, und dieser Restzweifel,
es könnte ja doch irgendwas sein,
der macht dich dann komplett fertig.
Ja.
Also so kann man sich das vorstellen. Ich meine,
ich wünsche das übrigens niemandem, dass der,
dass man sowas bekommt, ja.
Aber so, so ist das.
Ja,
Das ist jetzt genauso, das, nehmen wir mal das Beispiel von mir, ich habe da sowas Millimeterkleines irgendwie ertastet, was niemand irgendwie überhaupt merken würde, ich merke das, ja, und denke, boah, ich muss gleich hier irgendwie unten am Kinn, das muss so ein Tumor sein.
Das ist rational betrachtet kompletter Blödsinn.
Ja, das ist, das ist kompletter Blödsinn, das ist 0,0001% Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da irgendwie wirklich was Schlimmes ist.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich das schon Jahre und habe es auch schon gemerkt,
aber nichts. Aber ich denke mir,
das könnt ihr doch.
Und das macht mich dann tagelang fertig.
Tja.
So ist das.
So, aber jetzt haben wir genug darüber geredet.
Ich kann euch zumindest
nur empfehlen, falls ihr auch solche Probleme
habt, ja.
Und ihr Vertrauen habt
zu eurem Hausarzt,
dass ihr das mit dem besprecht
die sind da oftmals
schlauer als man denkt
und sei es nur
dass die euch woanders noch
hinschicken
also bei mir war das so
übrigens wenn ihr
schon einen schlechten Eindruck von eurem Hausarzt habt
und da eigentlich nur hingeht, weil ihr ab und zu eine
Krankmeldung für
für eine Erkältung braucht
dann besprecht das mit dem nicht
weil schlechte Ärzte machen die Sache
bloß noch schlimmer
Ja, also wenn ihr zu einem arzt geht er dann sagt machen sie sich nicht so viel gedanken wird schon nichts sein
Das ist das schlechteste was es gibt ja
Ihr braucht da schon ein
Der damit euch auf eine art und weise redet die euch hilft ja
Wenn ihr schon denkt das ist ein depp dann geht woanders hin aber bei mir war das auch so
Ich wir haben einiges bei meinem bei meiner ärztin ausprobiert und die hat dann auch irgendwann zu mir gesagt
gehen sie doch einfach mal in die ambulante sprechstunde in frankfurt hat
mir auch eine adresse gegeben hier in der eine psychiatrie in frankfurt haben
eine ambulante sprechstunde gehen sie da doch mal hin und besprechen sie das mit
denen die haben da auch viel mehr erfahrung was medikamente und sowas
angeht und ich wollte ja erst nicht ich habe gesagt ich gehe doch nicht in die
psychiatrie alles ist das hier gesagt ich habe ja die behalten mich gleich da
oder war am pott aber ich habe das dann gemacht und bin dann dahin und das hat
wirklich was gebracht ja die haben dann auch gesagt wenn es wenn es gar nicht
wenn es gar nicht besser wird sie haben auch eine tagesklinik in frankfurt da
kann man sich auch für anmelden habe ich auch gemacht aber dann ging es mir
eigentlich ganz gut und hab mir gedacht, na gut, das
auf gut Glück muss ich das jetzt
auch nicht machen. Also, es ist auf jeden
Fall besser, anstatt
das Wochen- und Monat lang auszusitzen.
Weil
eins darf man nicht vergessen,
so mal so vielleicht als, jetzt nicht
zum Panik machen, aber so als
Mini-Motivation tatsächlich da mal,
wenn man da Probleme hat, hinzugehen.
Also, man wird das alles irgendwie
los. So mal so zur Beruhigung,
ja? Es dauert ein bisschen,
okay? Man wird das alles, bei mir ist das
auch schon viel, viel besser als früher. Auch wenn ich es
manchmal selbst nicht wahrhaben will.
Manchmal, besonders wenn ich wieder so Tage habe,
wo es schlecht ist, denke ich mir, siehste, ist überhaupt
nichts besser geworden. Ist alles noch genauso beschlissen.
Objektiv gesehen ist es bei mir auch schon viel, viel
besser geworden. Also
irgendwie kriegt man das alles wieder weg.
Es dauert eine Weile. Aber
ähm
es bringt nichts,
das alles alleine zu machen.
weil unser Gehirn steht extrem drauf auf Sachen, die es kennt
egal ob das gute Sachen oder schlechte Sachen sind
wenn das Gehirn sich an was gewöhnt hat, dann macht es das gerne
oder macht es es gerne, ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, dann wiederholt es das
und man kann sich auch an unangenehme Sachen gewöhnen
hat vielleicht ein bisschen den Vorteil, es macht einem dann nicht mehr so viel aus,
aber es bleibt trotzdem unangenehm.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Und man muss sich das tatsächlich aktiv abgewöhnen.
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Weil wie gesagt, das Gehirn steht extrem auf so bekannte Abläufe.
Und das kriegt man allein relativ schlecht hin, sich so Sachen wieder abzugewöhnen.
Ja, und deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt, tatsächlich mal mit seinem Arzt zu reden, wenn man damit Probleme hat, vielleicht auch eine Therapie zu machen, im besten Fall, wenn es ganz besonders, also wenn es gut funktionieren soll und wenn es auch belastend ist, ist am besten natürlich die Kombination Therapie plus Pillen.
nicht einfach random sich irgendwas einschmeißen oder so,
vom Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof,
sondern das wirklich, das dann auch nehmen, ja,
nicht googeln nach Nebenwirkungen oder sonst was,
sondern einfach mal sagen, okay, ich vertraue denen
und ich mache das, was sie sagen.
Therapie plus Pillen ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Und das macht man dann, man muss dann auch gar nicht dran denken,
ah, in drei Wochen muss ich dann aber damit aufhören,
Ihr könnt das auch 2, 3, 4, 5, 8, manche Leute nehmen 15 Jahre den Scheiß.
Solange es hilft, ist es auch gut.
Und die meisten Nebenwirkungen sind überhaupt nicht so schlimm und sind nach den ersten paar Wochen wieder weg.
Man darf sich da auch nicht so davon stressen lassen, dass, ich habe auch den Fehler gemacht und habe gegoogelt
und du findest sonst was für Nebenwirkungen in 0,001% der Fälle, was das irgendwie haben kann.
Aber das ist alles nicht so schlimm, man geht ja eh regelmäßig zum Doktor, lässt sich das nachgucken.
Wichtig ist, dass der Kram hilft.
Und wenn man den Kram nimmt regelmäßig, dann wird auch die Angst vor Nebenwirkungen geringer.
Also, Problem ist nur, wenn man es wirklich so...
Genau, Beipackzettel ist eine blöde Idee.
Ich habe da auch mit meinem Arzt schon drüber geredet, die haben auch gemeint,
ja, da stehen halt viele Sachen drauf, was Leute haben,
die das in sehr hoher Dosierung nehmen, seit 20 Jahren und so, dann kann mal irgendwas auftreten,
aber oftmals nimmt man ja noch nicht mal hohe Dosierung.
Oftmals reicht ja schon ein Drittel oder ein Viertel von dem, was man eigentlich am Tag nehmen soll,
oder was man nehmen darf, oder noch viel weniger, dass das ganz gut wirkt,
und dann hat man da auch keine Nebenwirkungen.
Vielleicht die ersten ein, zwei Wochen, dass man ein bisschen nervös ist oder sowas, aber dann ist gut.
wichtig ist tatsächlich bei solchen sachen immer den doktor fragen und nicht sagen
ich behalte das jetzt mal im hinterkopf und machen wir da drei wochen gedanken drüber
wenn man schon beim doktor das kann man auch gleich sagen ich habe bedenken wegen nebenwirkungen und
es beruhigt halt auch wenn er dann sagt bei der dosierung und so passiert überhaupt nichts
ja es ist ja es ist echt so und man kriegt das alleine schlechthin und und was ich auch
nicht machen würde es in irgendwelche apps verwenden die dann irgendwelche für ihn es
gibt ja jede menge so psychologen apps und was ganz ehrlich da halte ich jetzt nichts von
da halte ich nichts von es viel besser sich sowas zu suchen aber das in kombination das
hilft ja und was was tatsächlich was mich auch beruhigt hat ist dass das wird mir an
mehreren stellen erzählt dass bis zu bis zu 35 prozent glaube ich war dass der leute im
im Lauf des Lebens sowas haben.
Und man rechnet sogar eher mit an die 50%,
weil viele einfach nicht zum Arzt gehen und denken,
ich sitze es irgendwie aus.
Also das ist eines der häufigsten,
neben Depressionen,
eines der häufigsten Erkrankungen,
so psychische Erkrankungen, die es gibt,
dass man so Angstzustände hat.
Also man ist da nicht der Einzige, der sowas hat.
Auch wenn man oft denkt,
so schlimm hat das keiner
oder keiner versteht es und keiner weiß es.
Doch, doch.
Das haben ganz viele.
Natürlich redet man da nicht so drüber.
Also es setzt sich keiner in der Mittagspause hin und sagt,
ey, übrigens habe ich dir schon erzählt, ich habe eine Angststörung.
Das wird jetzt eher nicht so oft vorkommen.
Ja, aber gerade wenn man mit den Leuten mal drüber redet, wird man, ich sehe es ja auch im Chat öfters, gerade wenn man mit den Leuten mal drüber redet, wird man feststellen, wie viele Leute da Probleme haben, von denen man das auch nie gedacht hätte oder man gar nicht vermutet hätte oder so.
Also es ist viel verbreiteter und man kann sagen, es gibt sehr viel Erfahrung mit solchen Erkrankungen.
Und es geht auch wieder weg.
Wenn man sich drum kümmert.
Das dauert, man darf nicht erwarten, dass das irgendwie von heute auf morgen oder so wieder weg geht.
Das kann auch mal gut 5, 6, 7, 8 Jahre dauern, bis alles komplett wieder weg ist.
Aber wichtig ist ja, dass man es langsam in den Griff kriegt und allein schon, dass man sieht, dass man Progress macht.
Also nicht mehr so schlimm ist wie vor einem halben Jahr oder sowas.
Motiviert auch und man steigert sich schon gar nicht mehr so stark beim nächsten Mal rein.
Ja, mir fällt das auch schwierig.
Mir fällt das auch schwer.
Ich glaube es teilweise selber ja auch nicht.
Ja gut.
So.
Jetzt haben wir aber genug darüber geredet.
Falls irgendjemand, falls es irgendjemand
da Probleme hat oder so,
ihr könnt mich gerne im Chat oder so
fragen, sonst habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Aber das hier ist ja natürlich keine Beratung
im eigentlichen Sinne. Ich kann euch nur sagen,
was ich da denke.
Übrigens,
eine Sache hätte ich tatsächlich noch,
die mir auch sehr geholfen hat.
Das kannst du vergessen. Ganz ehrlich,
wenn du kein gutes Verhältnis zu deinem Chef hast
und das eh jemand ist, würde ich
das gar nicht erwähnen.
Weil das
können viele Leute nicht
verstehen. Deswegen habe ich ja euch versucht,
für Leute, die sowas noch nicht
halbwegs so erklären, so mit diesem
Traktor-Pulling-Beispiel.
Das trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Man kann sich das schlecht
vorstellen, wenn man sowas noch nicht hatte.
Ja, was mir
tatsächlich ganz gut geholfen hat, ist
laut
meinem Psychologe, was
aus der
Depressionsspirale
oder sowas, aber gilt
genauso für
Angststörungen.
Und zwar, ich muss mal
gucken, äh Sekunde, ich muss mal in der
Vorschau gucken, ob ich das irgendwo finde. Ich will jetzt
nicht einfach danach googeln. Wartet mal,
ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Hm.
Ich finde jetzt dazu nichts.
Weil ich euch das tatsächlich gern zeigen würde, weil das fand ich sehr beruhigend.
Tja, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, das ist ja wahrscheinlich nix.
Ich muss doch kurz googeln danach.
Ansonsten lese ich euch das einfach vor.
Ah ja, doch hier.
Ja, doch.
Hier.
Ähm.
Also das hat mich sehr beruhigt.
Weil man sich da an vielen Stellen selbst wiedererkennt.
Wiki, Wikipedia, kognitive Verzerrungen.
Das hat mir mein Psychologe gezeigt.
der hat mir das als Arbeitsplatz geschickt, aus irgendeinem Psychologiebuch, aber das ist das, also, und zwar, egal ob es jetzt, also wie gesagt, ich habe davon keine Ahnung, ich habe das nicht gelernt oder sonst was, ich kann euch nur meine Erfahrungen berichten, ja, also, sagt jetzt nicht irgendwie, ja, so ist es, der Max hat es gesagt, das will ich jetzt nochmal ganz klar sagen, bevor wir da anfangen, aber mich hat das sehr beruhigt, weil ich habe immer gedacht, so, ey, diese Art und Weise, wie ich mir da Gedanken mache und so, das macht doch sonst keiner,
und ich habe das auch immer dann extrem überbewertet zum Beispiel.
So nach dem Motto, 1% Wahrscheinlichkeit habe ich im Kopf aufgeblasen wie 80% oder so.
Und es gibt, das hat mir mein Psychologe erzählt, es gibt da tatsächlich sogar Untersuchungen zu,
Leute, die Depressionen haben, die Angststörungen haben, die folgen oftmals bestimmten Denkmustern,
die man erkennen muss, um das besser einzuordnen.
Das ist was, was mir geholfen hat.
Ja, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel so Sachen wie...
Moment.
Irgendwie gab es doch hier...
Hier, genau.
Schwarz-Weiß-Denken und sowas.
Alles oder Nichts denken zum Beispiel. Da findet man sich relativ schnell hinterher. Emotionale Beweisführung. So nach dem Motto, ah, ich habe jetzt gedacht XY, das wird auch so sein. Oder wenn nicht alles ganz klar ist, so schwarz-weiß denken, wenn nicht alles ganz klar ist, dann ist es, also wenn nicht alles hundertprozentig sicher ist, dann ist es automatisch schlecht und solche Sachen.
Ja, das kann man sich hier mal durchlesen und gucken, ob man sich da selbst wiederfindet.
So, auch hier Etikettierung ist auch sowas nach dem Motto, es war schon immer scheiße, also wird es auch immer scheiße sein, ja.
Mir ging es gestern schlecht, das heißt, mir wird es auch die ganze Woche wieder schlecht gehen und solche Geschichten.
Also das sind quasi so Verzerrungen, die man im Kopf hat, die viel objektivere Sichtweisen gar nicht zulassen.
Also das hat mir tatsächlich sehr geholfen zu sehen, dass die Art und Weise, wie ich denke im Kopf mit dieser Problematik, dass das bekannt ist und untersucht ist.
Und man findet sich hier total schnell wieder.
her zum beispiel hier hat das profis ihren vergrößern die falsche annahme
dass das muss jetzt hin das kennen die das kennt bestimmt jeder
der schon mal was in der richtung hat hier die falsche annahme dass das
schlimmste weil es vorstellbar ist mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit auch
tatsächlich eintreten wird ist dass das kennen jeder solche probleme schon mal
hatte.
Also man sagt, einen schlechten
Ausgang voraus, ohne wahrscheinlichere
Möglichkeiten zu bedenken.
Und solche Dinge, das hat
mich wahnsinnig beruhigt,
diese Seite, ich habe das als
Arbeitsplatz, diese
Seite mir durchzulesen
und
sich selbst in den einzelnen Punkten
wiederzuerkennen und zu erkennen,
aha, nur weil ich
das jetzt denke,
muss das gar nicht so wirklich sein.
Habe ich denn vielleicht andere Aspekte komplett verdrängt im Kopf, die viel wahrscheinlicher sind?
Also das kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen, sich das mal durchzulesen und zu gucken, wo man sich da wiederfindet, wenn man so Probleme hat.
Wenn wir feststellen, man tappt in ganz viele dieser Fallen rein.
Ja, dass man dann irgendwelche Schlussfolgerungen trifft
Aufgrund dieser Verzerrungen
Also das ist, wie gesagt, das ist eine Sache, die mich ultra beruhigt hat
So
Ja klar, jeder wird sich da irgendwie wiederfinden.
Problematisch ist es nur, wenn es so viele Probleme macht, dass das halt einen Großteil des Lebens bestimmt.
Ja, wenn man einmal gedacht hat, boah, morgen habe ich ein Vorstellungsgespräch, das wird ganz furchtbar schlimm werden.
Ja gut, dann ist das vorbei und dann ist es gut.
Wenn jetzt aber jemand jeden Tag sich dachte, oh, morgen muss ich aber in Edeka fahren, da werde ich bestimmt überfahren.
Oh ne, nachher muss ich aber irgendwie den Herd anschalten, da fackelt mir bestimmt die Bude ab oder sowas in der Richtung.
Dann kann man schon sagen, okay, man neigt wahrscheinlich dazu, gerade sowas überzubewerten.
überzubewerten.
Und es geht ja auch nicht darum, dass das immer
haltlos ist, ja.
Wenn man morgen ein Vorstellungsgespräch
hat und denkt, oh, das wird bestimmt ganz schlecht,
naja, es ist ja sicherlich nicht verkehrt,
es geht ja nicht darum, es komplett
beiseite zu wischen und zu sagen, oh nee, das kann
ja überhaupt nicht sein. Aber es
schadet da auch nichts. Selbst bei
einfachen Sachen wie, oh, morgen habe ich ein Vorstellungsgespräch,
das wird bestimmt ganz schlimm, es schadet
ja auch nichts, sich da mal zu überlegen, okay,
überbewerte ich das jetzt nicht vielleicht
ja, also
steige ich mich da nicht vielleicht rein
ich bin so und mal realistisch
betrachtet, okay
ich hab mich gut drauf vorbereitet
ich hab die Webseite von denen
gelesen, bisher war da
Bewerbungsprozess gut
ich weiß
gut Bescheid über das was ich mache
also sprich
ist dieses Denken, morgen wird ganz furchtbar
schlimm, ist das wirklich gerechtfertigt
Ja, und wenn ich sage, ja, okay, in dem und dem Bereich habe ich vielleicht keine Ahnung, ja, dann gucke ich es mir vielleicht vorher nochmal an. Also es schadet ja auch, ohne dass man so eine Erkrankung hat, nicht manchmal so ein bisschen zu hinterfragen, was man so denkt. Das muss ja nicht immer schlecht sein. Und, also mir hat das auf jeden Fall geholfen.
Ja, das ist eine gesunde Einstellung
Es kommt so wie es kommt
Wenn das nicht dazu führt
Dass du dir Gedanken machst, ist das vollkommen fein
Aber wenn du dir Gedanken machst
Jetzt auch vielleicht nicht im krankhaften Ausmaß
Und super Angst immer hast
Vor Präsentationen oder Vorstellungsgesprächen
Oder sonst was
Das ist ja nichts, wo man wirklich zum Psychologe muss damit. Aber selbst da schadet es nicht, sich mal zu überlegen, okay, wie wahrscheinlich ist das jetzt eigentlich wirklich, dass das so schlimm wird, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Ist das nicht vielleicht total überbewertet?
guck mal, ich habe die letzten 5 Vorstellungsgespräche
auch keine Probleme gehabt
weil man vergisst so Sachen oftmals
man steigert sich dann total rein und sagt
oh ne, oh ne, oh ne, und morgen Vorstellungsgespräch
oh ich weiß jetzt schon, das wird ganz schlimm, ich kriege kein Wort
dabei raus, ja und umso mehr
man sich da reinsteigert, umso mehr vergisst
du auch alles, was links und rechts ist
und konzentrierst dich nur noch auf die Katastrophe
also es kann jedem, kann jedem passieren
ja, aber es kommt wie es kommt
ist eine super Einstellung, wenn man das kann
Das ist eigentlich eines der besten Einstellungen, die man haben kann, so für, ähm, ähm, grübeln und, und, und, ähm,
also, so, so, so, so Angstzustände im Kopf, wenn man sagt, ey, weißt du was, juckt mich nicht, kommt wie es kommt,
wenn man das, wenn man das kann, dann ist das ja alles in Ordnung.
So, jetzt wollte ich euch bloß zeigen, weil das hat mir sehr geholfen zu sehen, okay, es gibt da sogar Untersuchungen zu
und gerade so die Art und Weise, wie ich denke, ist wohl sehr wahrscheinlich, kommt wohl sehr oft vor.
So, dann gucken wir jetzt mal.
Oh, Katzi, Katzi.
Dann gucken wir jetzt mal.
Was trendet denn so auf GitHub?
Ja.
Ey, es gibt Sachen.
Also so schlimm war es bei mir noch nicht.
Das habe ich aber auch schon gelesen.
So, dass man dann quasi
sich so ein bisschen von außen sieht.
So nach dem Motto,
das was hier passiert, sehe ich jetzt nicht mehr durch meine eigenen Augen,
sondern so wie auf einer Theaterbühne und sowas.
Also das Hirn kann ganz viele abgedrehte Sachen.
Gibt es einen Fix mit Experiencing Interruptions of YouTube mit U-Block Origin?
Ich habe noch keinen gefunden.
Was ich mache ist, also was bei mir besser funktioniert ist, Firefox.
Firefox mit dem originalen U-Block Origin.
Bilde ich mir zumindest ein, dass das besser funktioniert.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass das einfach nur eingebildet ist.
So, also schauen wir mal.
Was trendet denn diese Woche auf GitHub?
Ja, YouTube Premium hilft natürlich auch.
Dann gibt es gar keine Werbung.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange es keine Werbung gibt.
Weil es war bei Amazon Prime am Anfang auch so.
Hast du Prime, hast du keine Werbung bekommen.
Und mittlerweile bezahlst du Prime und kriegst trotzdem Werbung.
Also das ist alles ein bisschen...
Die machen das, womit sie quasi davon kommen.
mal gespannt wie lange es bei youtube premium dauert bis es dann quasi die werden das irgendwie
die die machen das ja immer so salami taktik mäßig die werden nicht einfach bei youtube premium sagen
von heute auf morgen gibt es werbung die werden dann erst mal sagen ja wir planen ihnen jetzt
zu ihrer history passend kaufempfehlung unten ein und dann wird es immer mehr so
lang wie sie halt in ihren analytics feststellen dass die leute sich das noch gefallen lassen
end certification ja
ok also was haben wir hier
KI. KI. AI. AI. AI. AI. Nee. Doch. AI.
AI
Nicht AI
Alter
Sehe ich das richtig?
Wir hatten bis auf ein Repo alles KI diesmal
Krass.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal,
was trennt bei Go.
Ein
Vulnerability Scanner.
Oh ja.
Subtoapi.
AI.
AI?
Singthing.
Das habe ich ja schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
AI.
Vault trendet.
ganz ehrlich das fände ich auch mega also ich habe mir schon öfters überlegt wie wäre es denn
wenn man hier also man kann ja repos guck mal man kann ja repos taggen wie wärs denn wenn so
ein paar vorgefertigte kategorien quasi gebe von github wo man auch danach filtern könnte
beziehungsweise die man rausfiltern könnte, ja?
Dass man unter anderem KI rausfiltern könnte.
Oder Krypto rausfiltern könnte oder sowas.
Aber ich glaube, das wollen die nicht,
weil das ist, wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen,
wir reden ja hier letztendlich von Microslop.
Hast du das mit Cloud Mythos mitbekommen, ja?
Ja.
Oder was genau?
Also habe ich mitbekommen, dass das existiert, ja.
Und dass es wohl angeblich in Firefox auch ganz viele Sachen wohl gefunden hat.
Ich würde sagen, KI.
KI.
Der TypeScript Go Port.
Ist der eigentlich schon ready?
Jetzt?
Der TypeScript Port
written in Go.
Ja.
Ne, der ist noch nicht fertig.
Deepseek.
GitHub CLI.
Ja, wenn ich irgendwann mal ein Solarpanel habe, dann werde ich mir auch EVCC installieren. Elektroauto habe ich schon, aber ohne Photovoltaik macht das ja hier mit EVCC wenig Sinn.
Ich habe eine Wallbox, die man per MQTT wunderbar abfragen kann, beziehungsweise sogar steuern kann teilweise.
Ein Elektroauto, wenn ich ja so ein Solarpanel hätte und vielleicht noch eine Batterie, könnte man da viel machen, aber das ist mir zur Zeit zu aufwendig.
Pocket Base.
Ey, das ist Trended mal was, was nicht KI ist.
Nice.
Sift.
Was genau darf ich mir darunter vorstellen?
Ist das so ein Dependency Scanner oder was?
Also der guckt, welche Teile in dem Image alles drin sind oder was oder wie?
Okay, Zipf Pulling Images, Head
Mal kurz gucken, was das macht
Ups.
Äh.
Das check ich jetzt aber nicht so genau.
Äh, was?
Was?
Ah, das guckt quasi, was alles in den Images drin ist, damit man das dann in irgendeinen Vulnerability Scanner pipen kann.
sagt die motor da ist noch erst drauf oder sowas ok ok ok ja ja verstehe
das kann das denn alles kennen
ich brauche eine get implementation in go
In Rust könnte ich mir noch vorstellen, weil in Rust wird alles rewritten, ob es Sinn macht oder nicht.
Achso, okay, das ist eine Git-Library für Go.
Okay, das macht natürlich mehr Sinn.
Ja, ja, das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll.
dass man Git-Repos aus Go
manipulieren kann. Ja, das macht es.
Git-Level.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was
trendet denn bei den Krustentieren
so.
RuView.
Wi-Fi Dance
Post.
Real Human
Post. Moment, Moment.
Die
wollen mit Wi-Fi
signalen, mit Wi-Fi
irgendwie erkennen,
wie und wo sich Leute in einem Raum
befinden oder was.
Das ist doch KI generiert das Bild, oder?
Was es nicht alles gibt, ey.
A minimal secure Python Interpreter.
Das ist doch garantiert, garantiert AI-Slop, oder?
Ja, ist es.
Oder auch nicht.
Wo ist denn hier der Source Code jetzt eigentlich?
Bin ich jetzt dumm? Ich erkenne es nicht.
Crates?
Oder wo?
Ah ja, hier.
Nein, ist keine KI.
Was hat das jetzt damit zu tun?
Achso, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ich meinte, das hier ist
KI-Slob, oder?
Python-Interpreter in Rust.
Weil da sehe ich schon als erstes, dass
Cloud-Code am Start ist.
Okay.
KI.
Comfortably monitor your Internet traffic.
Brauche ich da... Braucht man da sowas?
Ach, sowas ist das. Okay.
Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, im Zweifelfall, wenn ich was wissen will, Wireshark.
Aber sowas ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Das siehst du ungefähr... Ja, das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ey, das gefällt mir. Das muss ich mal bei mir daheim ausprobieren.
Das muss ich mir mal bookmarken.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Sowas finde ich gut.
Haben wir tatsächlich ein interessantes Projekt gefunden, Chad?
Wahnsinn.
Cross-Platform, äh,
Jimmy Nye, Rust Desk, das ist hier
Team-Viewer-Alternative.
Vom Hörensagen.
Ich hab's selbst noch nie verwendet. Chatgear, einer von euch
schon mal Rust Desk verwendet?
Verwenden die indischen Scammer mittlerweile Rust Desk?
Oder immer noch Any Desk und TeamViewer?
Hold on, hold on.
Ma'am.
Don't redeem.
Don't redeem, ma'am.
ab und zu gucke ich auch mal ganz gerne so scambaiting videos ich habe früher regelmäßig
kitboga geguckt als der ist der kann der hat das wirklich drauf muss man sagen ja aber jeden tag
kann ich mir das auch nicht angucken das wird auch langweilig mit der zeit scambaiting content
Ach die nutzen auch Rustesk, okay.
Counter Strike 2 Offset Dumper. Okay, was auch immer. Hackerman Tools Z. Mikro Sandbox.
Für KI Zeug zum Ausführen. Hast du das? Supply Chain Attack
bei Bitworn mitbekommen. Nee, hab ich
nicht.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
NPM-Paket
von Bitworn kompromittiert.
Alter, es ist so schlimm
mittlerweile. Der Fuck.
NPM-Paket von Bitworn
kompromittiert. Sag mal,
was haben die sich eigentlich,
Das regt mich jedes Mal auf. Ich habe ja früher regelmäßig Golem gelesen.
Aber die neue Golem-Webseite, die ist so abfuck.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie da gemacht haben.
Angreifer haben erfolgreich Shardcode.
Shardcode. Das ist so ein Semper-Video-Wort, oder?
Shardcode.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Der Shardcode.
Gibt es den eigentlich noch?
Oh, der macht auch keine Videos mehr oder hat schon eine Weile keine Videos mehr gemacht.
Auf Twitch weiß ich, auf Twitch spielt er manchmal Armer.
Okay, Angreifer haben ja vollständig...
dahinter steckt eine größere angriffskampagne ok entwickler das
weitverbreitende passwort mann mit worten hat einen erfolgreichen supply
auf das npm sie kann man sie ok bitwarn cli
ok bla bla bla zwischen 23 31 passwort resort der nutzer soll durch den
Vorfall nicht gefährdet sein.
Gut, wäre ja auch
merkwürdig,
wenn
das direkt irgendwie angegriffen werden könnte.
Was halt sein könnte, ist, dass du den
Keylogger einfängst und das nächste Mal halt das...
Ja und? Ja und?
Was war jetzt genau drinne?
Angreifer sammeln
Anmeldedaten. Ja doch.
Nähere Details zum Angriff sind unter...
Blablabla. Demnach wurde bei dem NPM-Paket eine BW1-JS-Datei mit Schadcode eingeschleust.
Angriffspunkt war eine kompromittierte GitHub-Action.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
Die Attacke steht wohl mit einer K... Blablabla.
Ja, und die Angreifer haben es unter anderem auf Schlüssel, Token und andere Anmeldeinformationen für SSH-Zugänge.
Okay, der Klassiker. GitHub sowie NPM Cloud-Konten.
ja npm damit sie weitere sachen supply chain angreifen können
ja schon scheiße deswegen versuche ich so wenig wie möglich zeug noch zu programmieren
auf meiner linux kiste hier direkt sondern nur noch in dev container der sport weil dann ist
ist halt wenigstens gesandboxed
so was trennt denn sonst noch so geht butter er geht geht guis allen bei mir
immer nie auf die gefallen ja polymarket cli das klingt nach crypto stellt vermutlich
ip-adresse break
was was soll das sein less network um ein less network for networks
Was?
You can connect? Was?
Okay.
Ich hab das jetzt gelesen.
Chat, bin ich der Einzige, der das nicht checkt?
Die wollen uns erklären, was das ist.
Ich checke null, was das bedeutet.
Iroh gives you an API
for dealing, dialing
by public key.
What? Man wählt mit public key?
You say connect
to that phone?
Also die haben bei sich eine Daten...
Letztendlich brauchst du doch unter der Haube IP-Adressen.
Wie sollst du sonst hinkommen?
Ah.
Okay, die haben irgendwie...
Dann haben die aber bei sich irgendwie so einen Master-Server,
der das checkt, oder?
Oder man kann selbst hosten.
Also du brauchst einen Server im Internet draußen,
dass das funktioniert.
Kannst du mir erklären, wie das mit den SSH-Schlüsseln funktioniert?
Wie, was jetzt genau?
Bei Iroh? Ich hab keine Ahnung, hab ich ja nie verwendet.
Oder meinst du SSH an sich selbst?
Oder was?
Also SSH selbst ist eigentlich
klassisches Public-Private-Key-Gedöns.
Du generierst ein Public und ein Private Key
Der Private Key bleibt nur bei dir auf dem Rechner
Auf dem Server wird der Public Key hinterlegt
Und wenn du dich einloggst, musst du beweisen, dass du den dazugehörigen Private Key zu dem dort hinterlegten Public Key hast
Das kannst du nur beweisen, indem du den Private Key hast
So, was da noch passiert ist
Der Server Key wird gehasht, bei dir lokal gespeichert
Damit du erkennst, wenn sich der Server ändert
Es könnte ja jemand hingehen, den Server austauschen mit der gleichen IP und du verbindest dich auf einmal drauf und denkst, aha, das ist der Server von gestern, dabei ist es gar nicht mehr der Server von gestern.
Deswegen hasht SSH nochmal den Server-Key bei dir lokal und merkt sich das.
Da bekommst du dann so eine Fehlermeldung und sagst, ah, der Server-Key hat sich geändert.
Aber ansonsten, SSH, Public Private Key Authentifizierung, ist so mit das Klassischste, was man so kennt.
Public Private Key Authentifizierung ist möglich, möglich, möglichkeitenmäßig.
Der Private Key verlässt nie deinen Rechner und du beweist beim Login quasi, dass du den dazugehörigen Private Key zu dem dort hinterlegten Public Key hast.
so ich wusste auch mal vor ein paar jahren konnte ich so einen
key exchange von hand machen also von hand meine ich mit kleinen zahlen rein theoretisch
rechnerisch das kriege ich aber aus dem kopf nicht mehr hin also ich habe mal diesen diesen
diesen wie heißt das noch mal die sind diesen die sind diesen key austausch prozess wurde dann
irgendwie dir unabhängig von anderer geheime nummern ausdenkst dann davon
irgendwie was war das modulo machst oder irgendwie sowas und und und dann irgendwie
mit einer prim zahlen noch irgendwas machst und dann würde ich quasi über eine
public leitung auf den gemeinsamen privaten schlüssel einigen kannst ja so
genau ich glaube das war es das habe ich mir vor jahren mal angeguckt da konnte
das auf dem Papier machen? Das kann ich aber
nicht mehr. Das weiß ich nicht mehr, wie das
funktioniert.
Wird dann der Hash von einem Privaten übertragen
oder wie funktioniert das?
Ach so, meinst du das?
Ja, das ist gut.
Das ist eines der Sachen, wo ich keine Ahnung habe,
wie es funktioniert.
Also ich vermute mal, das ist jetzt geraten, ja.
Ich vermute mal, dass dort halt mit dem Public Key was verschlüsselt wird.
Und das kriegst du geschickt.
So, der Server weiß ja, was er verschlüsselt hat.
also der server verschlüsselt ein nur ihm bekannten text mit einem public key dann
schickt er dir das verschlüsselte und dadurch dass du quasi das entschlüsseln kannst und
ihm die gültige antwort übermitteln kannst weiß der server dass du den gültigen private
hast aber ehrlich gesagt so hundertprozentig weiß ich auch nicht wie genau das funktioniert
da gibt es garantiert irgendeinen irgendein bild für ja
ja hier guckt da da gibt's doch request connection server response mit ja gut das
ist ja eigentlich das
da gibt es irgendwie schatten boah was das ist das ist hier für die okay wenn
du es genau wissen willst keine ahnung du hast mich ertappt ich habe keinen
blassen schimmer ja ich vermute aber trotzdem dass das so grob gesagt
vereinfacht läuft wie das wie ich gerade beschrieben habe
max ein audio ist manchmal leicht leicht disordert okay kann das sein dass
wenn ich zu laut rede oder so
also wenn ich zu laut rede so wie eben war das dann so da muss ich vielleicht
mal neust neust etwas einstellen
okay das ist komisch es ist windows logik wer weiß wer weiß
was was windows da wieder treibt ja
also wenn du es genau wissen willst gibt es da anscheinend jede menge bilder zu
aber ganz ehrlich das ist jetzt auch so über meinen kopf wie das genau funktioniert
es ist servo nicht css in rust doch oder
ist das nicht ich sage nicht css in rust
prototype web browser engine okay das ist komplette browser mittlerweile
Wie dabei ist Windows-Logik?
Hä?
Was ist denn da los?
Habt ihr das auch gerade gehört?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sekunde.
Ähm.
Moment.
Ich spiele nicht am Kabel.
Muss ich mir das mal selbst anhören.
Oh Gott, Twitch, Alter.
Jetzt hängt der scheiß Browser wegen Twitch.
Was ist denn da los?
WTF, der Browser ist ge...
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Classic.
Okay, ich hatte das Problem schon mal.
Und es lag da dran, dass ich zu viele von diesen Dingern hier übereinander gestapelt habe.
Aber das wird es ja nicht sein.
Und ich fürchte, an OBS liegt das auch nicht.
Das liegt hier, das liegt bestimmt wirklich an meinem Kabel.
Wartet mal, wartet mal, wartet mal, wartet mal.
Ich stöpsel mal ein bisschen dran rum.
Test, Test, Test, Test, Test.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Das hat wirklich einen Wackelkontakt, das Kabel.
Leute.
Das ist broken.
Broken ist das Kabel.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es jetzt so hingelegt, dass es keine Probleme mehr macht.
Hört ihr mich wieder?
Ich hoffe, es funzt alles.
Test, Test, Test, ja.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung, was Windows da treibt.
Also.
Was trendet denn sonst noch?
Hatten wir schon was?
Hatten wir schon alles? Okay.
Dann schauen wir nochmal kurz, was bei AC Sharp so trendet.
Das ist meistens ja unspektakulär.
Osu! Osu trendet wieder!
Chat!
für die
für die Weeps unter uns.
Oso ist so ein Rhythmus
Rhythmus Game,
was nicht zwangsläufig
unbedingt
Anime Musik abspielen muss,
aber
gefühlt 99%
der Leute
damit Anime
Musik abspielen.
So, Git Credentials Manager, sowas braucht man nicht.
Bulk Crap Installer, das braucht man für Windows, ja.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was der WAND Enhancer sein soll.
Was der einhast.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Plastenschimmer.
Was das ist.
Keine Ahnung.
DPI-Aware-Mouse-Move-Across-Screens.
Ah, gut.
ASP.NET Core Trended.
Für mich immer noch, Leute, bestes Web-Framework.
kontext menü manager aus männer städten der manager chinesen zeug
man hat windows right click kontext menü
da kann man sagen ja das ist ja tatsächlich war richtig praktisch so
was fragt man sich warum sowas nicht standardmäßig in windows trainer ist na
da kann man das rechtsklick kontext menü ändern unter windows dass das finde
tatsächlich das ist mal sinnvolles sinnvolles tool ich mache ein bisschen
gedanken weil china chinesen software ist
windows mac os linux klein vorgeht users braucht kein mensch
trading engine jellyfin nur für linux distributionen wieder leute s box public
download web video und audio auch nur für linux distribution
ach das ist ein youtube dlp frontend kann aber youtube dlp verwenden auf der
kommandozeile
das kenne ich nicht motor und keine ahnung
So, dann haben wir, dann wissen wir, was jetzt trendet.
Wir wissen, dass wenig spannendes dabei war.
Ich glaube ein halbwegs spannendes Projekt war dabei.
Das ist ein Trommel und Rhythmus Spiel.
Trommel?
Also mit angeschlossenem Schlagzeug oder wie?
Machst du das?
Bist du Schlagzeug?
schlagzeug champ
dann würde ich sagen chat guck mal was uns youtube so empfiehlt heute
damals
so hin.
Bundesregierung auf Signal gehackt.
Naja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Da wurde nichts gehackt.
Die wurden social engineered, soweit
ich das richtig gelesen habe. Also es ist
jetzt nicht so, als hat da jemand
die Passwörter Brutforst oder so.
Gibt es die Stream-Ideenliste noch? Ja, klar.
Gibt es?
Die wird halt immer größer.
Was hast du denn für Ideen für die
Stream-Ideenliste?
Das erklärt er im Short auch so
Das dachte ich mir schon, Malfoy, das kennst du ja auch aus
Hast du schon das IPv8 Konzept gesehen?
Ich hab letztens ein Video dazu
Empfohlen bekommen
Dass irgendjemand IPv8
Als halber Troll
Oder so irgendwie eingereicht hat
Oder sowas, gell
Aber so richtig angeguckt hab ich mir das nicht
Niri müssen wir weiter einrichten
Verfolgst du eigentlich ein wenig das
Stop Killing Games Movement? Ganz am
Rande verfolge ich das
Da war letztens
irgendwie eine Anhörung in der EU
für diese Geschichte mit
dass gekaufte Games nicht mehr
quasi verfallen können, aber mehr
weiß ich dazu auch nicht
Ich weiß nur, dass
Pirate Software sich da echt selbst
so ein richtig großes dickes Ei damit
gelegt hat, weil der, das war
doch das, oder? Weil der da so
komplett dagegen war.
Und dann auch drauf bestanden
hat, dagegen zu sein.
Man hört von Pirate Software auch
gefühlt nichts mehr.
Seit der ganzen Geschichte.
Ich hab
Pirate Software auch nie großartig geguckt, also
keine Ahnung. Das
erste Mal, wo ich was von Pirate Software mitgekriegt
hat, war die Onlyfans
Geschichte, wo er
irgendwie aus der Instanz rausgeportet ist
und die Leute verreckt sind.
Das ist das erste Mal, wo ich so richtig was
mitgekriegt habe.
Every
Killed-Off Windows Feature
Explained in 9 Minuten. Reichen da
9 Minuten dafür?
Um jedes Windows Feature, was Microsoft
raus... Da reichen doch 9 Minuten
nicht mehr für.
Wir können
Talescale anschauen, da leake ich wieder meine IP.
Aber das ist
tatsächlich keine schlechte Idee.
Habe ich mich bisher
null mit beschäftigt? Ich meine, ich weiß, was es ist.
Warte mal, Talescale, das ist die
Cloudflare-Geschichte, oder?
Weil es gab doch noch irgendwas anderes, was die Leute
auch gerne verwendet haben.
War Talescale die Cloudflare-Geschichte,
oder ist Cloudflare wieder was anderes?
Ah, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Cloudflare Tunnel ist das andere.
Okay.
Das habe ich jetzt durcheinander gebracht.
Ja, ich habe da bisher noch keine
Anwendungszweck für gehabt in letzter Zeit.
Deswegen habe ich da auch nichts von ausprobiert.
Aber das können wir tatsächlich mal machen.
Keine schlechte idee einfach nur das noch mal gesehen hat man muss ja nicht unbedingt verwenden
So was haben wir denn sonst was wird mir denn sonst noch empfohlen das ist ein äußerst unglücklicher kamera finkel
Der link in spyware situation
Okay, wusste ich gar nicht, dass
Was macht denn LinkedIn da wieder?
Achso, ich dachte, es gibt wieder neue
Automationen-Video
Self-hosted apps that replace everything you pay for
Das ist halt einfach mal sinnloser Cheap-Bait
Wir gucken uns das Video nicht an
skipnetz einfach mal drüber jellyfin ok linux distribution bei holt braucht kein mensch reverse
proxy paid man normalerweise nicht vor proaktiv die apps ok home lab dashboard smart home services
backups monitore abteilung kummer ss o das sind das sind klar aber das ist das replaced garantiert
nicht everything you pay for.
Ja? Replace das
YouTube Premium. Ne, macht's nicht.
Replace das Netflix. Ne, macht's nicht.
Da sagen sie, ja, okay, du kannst dir ja
ein Usenet-Account holen, die alles per Jellyfell runterladen.
Ja, good luck, have fun.
Replace das
die App von meinem Staubsauger-Roboter.
Nein, machen sie auch. Macht's auch nicht.
Denkt ihr, dass die Randpreise wieder runtergehen?
Das kann aktuell keiner genau sagen
Ob wir das denken oder nicht, ist vollkommen unerheblich
Ich denke, dass die Randpreise wieder runtergehen
Ich weiß nur nicht wann
Aber mehr kann ich jetzt nur nicht sagen
Der Mann hinter dem Zeigefinger.
Was?
Nein.
Wir machen kein YouTube-Premium jetzt.
Sicherheitsrisiko.
Da wird auch wieder ein riesen Fass aufgemacht.
Die Franzosen wollen kein Windows mehr.
Das habe ich tatsächlich auch gehört, ja.
Okay, was gibt es bei CT3003 Neues?
Kein Mensch braucht WordPress.
Das sehe ich auch so.
Moment, was?
Eine Stunde 25.
Wie fängt man mit 3D-Druck an?
Ich habe einen 3D-Drucker.
schon lange nichts mehr gedruckt.
Okay, gibt's nichts Spannendes.
Okay, dann schauen wir doch mal.
Was mit der...
Das hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Hat das einer von euch mitbekommen oder ist das Clickbait?
LinkedIn Spyware.
Mal kurz drüber durchskippen.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist einfach nur G-Bait.
Ach ja?
Ich vergesse immer, dass LinkedIn Microsoft ist.
Geht es noch jemand so?
Irgendwie verbinde ich LinkedIn überhaupt nicht mit Microsoft.
Ich vergesse das immer.
Wie genau soll das funktionieren über den Browser?
Hat Microsoft da in Windows irgendwelche Sachen drin?
Weil mein Browser kann definitiv nicht suchen, was auf meinem PC installiert ist.
Was ich davon halte? Nix.
Solange die nicht hundertprozentig kompatibel sind, kannst du es vergessen.
Ich halte davon gar nichts.
Auf der anderen Seite juckt es mich auch nicht weiter, weil ich seit einigen Jahren Ubuntu komplett rausgeschmissen habe und wieder komplett auf Debian bin und bleibe. Und auf der Arbeit Red Hat, da kommen wir nicht drum herum. Geht nur in Edge.
dann haben die irgendeine
Schnittstelle da im Hintergrund, die nur
für Microsoft wieder zugänglich ist
wo man dann sich wieder fragt, da
wer nutzt die als nächstes aus
wie so Debian und nicht Ubuntu
das hat eigentlich zwei
Gründe, die es für mich so die
letzten Jahre über durchgezogen hat
Snap und
Netplan, mag ich beides nicht
ansonsten ist Ubuntu vollkommen fein
wenn man Support kaufen will, ist
Ubuntu auch vollkommen fein.
Welches NAS oder welches OS
testen wir heute? Stimmt, wir haben ja
Leute, mir ging es halt die letzten 14
Tage nicht gut. Sonst hätten wir das
der Serious Max, den muss ich ja das NAS langsamer
schicken.
Sonst hätten wir das
nicht das Minis Forum,
das Ukraine NAS nochmal ordentlich
getestet, aber
allein schon das Schwätzen,
das Schwätzen geht es mir jetzt schon wieder besser.
Nee, nee, das ist immer noch die alte Geschichte.
Auch wenn es insgesamt schon viel besser
ist, ab und zu
ist es halt mal ein bisschen
Durchhänger.
Ja gut, in Chrome geht's wahrscheinlich nicht, aber in Edge wird's wahrscheinlich gehen.
Moment.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass eine Webseite abfragen kann, was ich für Browser Extensions installiert habe.
Wusstet ihr, dass das geht?
Ja, und selbst wenn. Ich meine, es gibt Schlimmeres.
Es gibt Schlimmeres, oder?
Also so schlimm finde ich das jetzt an der Stelle ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht.
Ja, pff.
Okay.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, so schlimm finde ich das jetzt an der Stelle noch nicht.
Ich habe auch wenig Extensions installiert.
Also ich habe zwei bis drei Extensions.
Ich habe U-Block, ich habe dieses Volume-Regel-Ding, das ist für Streaming ganz praktisch.
Praktisch.
Und was habe ich sonst noch?
Dark Reader habe ich bei manchen Browsern noch.
Aber ansonsten...
Hier, und für Twitch in dem einen habe ich FFZ.
Ja, aber ansonsten...
Nix.
Ja, also bis jetzt sehe ich da jetzt noch nichts wahnsinnig Schlimmes.
Also ich frage mich jetzt zwei Sachen.
Erstens, was juckt die das, was ich für Extensions installiert habe?
Und zweitens, ist das jetzt so schlimm?
Fingerprint, sehr guter Punkt, Chat.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, ob es für Fingerprint genug ist.
Ja doch, sagen wir mal so, wenn du da irgendwie 30 Extensions installiert hast,
das dürfte dann schon relativ unix sein.
Aber es reicht ja auch schon, wenn man dich grob ein...
quasi einordnen kann.
Also du sagst, ah, okay,
wir vermuten, du bist der und der.
Wenn man jetzt noch die Extensions hinzuzieht,
dann bist du relativ wahrscheinlich der.
Ja.
Okay.
Die erkennen, ob du irgendwelche
Competitor verwendest.
die gucken, ob du irgendwelche Jobsearch-Dinger hast.
Die gucken, ob du Privacy-Kabel auflässt.
Religious Extensions.
Moment, es gibt Religious Extensions für den Browser?
Erstmal Bibel lesen.
Erstmal Koran im Browser lesen.
Hä?
But why?
Na gut.
Soll jeder glauben, was er will.
Ihr wisst, ich hab mit keinem irgendwas großartig am Hut.
Anti-Vogue.
Okay, warum interessiert das LinkedIn?
Auf LinkedIn ist doch eh so ein komplett eigenes Ökosystem aus quasi Brainwash-Leuten.
Ja, LinkedIn ist quasi so eine Art Religion.
Ja, aber an sich...
Alter.
An sich ist das Thema nicht ganz unspannend.
Ich habe nämlich mal gelesen,
es gab eine Untersuchung,
Also, da haben sie, das ist aber schon ein paar Jahre her, da haben sie Leute an so ein Gehirnstrommessgerät angeschlossen und die haben festgestellt, jetzt bin ich total eingeblieben, die haben festgestellt, dass bei Fans von bestimmten Marken,
Ich glaube, sie haben es mit Apple getestet, dass bei Apple-Fans quasi, wenn sie Apple-Produkte und Apple-Marketing-Sachen sehen, ähnliche Gehirne angesprochen werden, wie bei religiösen Leuten, wenn sie beten.
Also es werden quasi bei Apple-Jüngern im Endeffekt gleiche Areale im Gehirn angesprochen, wie bei Gläubigen, wenn sie sich mit Gott beschäftigen und so.
Das ist kein Spaß.
Da gab es wirklich eine Untersuchung zu.
Das ist aber schon ein paar Jahre her.
Aber ganz im Ernst,
Chat, Chat, Chat mal Hand aufs Herz.
Irgendwie haben wir das alle doch schon gedacht, oder?
Wie schaut das mit Linux-Leuten aus?
Ich könnte wetten,
ist genau das Gleiche.
Sobald du irgendwas ultra-Fanboyst,
wird es das Gleiche sein.
Playstation.
Früher.
Diese ganze Playstation,
Gaystation vs. Wixbox-Diskussion, wo sie sich gegenseitig immer geflamed haben.
So 2010 rum.
11, 12.
Das wird da ganz genauso sein.
ist an eine Organisation angewendet.
Also wenn du LinkedIn aus einem Werk-Computer
und du hast kostenlose Ausstellungen für dein Werk,
dann ist das, worauf es sich interessiert.
Das ist verrückt.
Das bedeutet, die Softwareinfrastruktur von Millionen...
Okay, das Video ist jetzt irgendwie...
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, was die Franzosen da so treiben.
Hatten wir nicht passend dazu mal irgendwann...
ein...
Bin ich jetzt blöd?
Wir hatten doch mal so ein Baguette-E-Mode.
Wo ist der? Ah! Kann man so selten verwenden.
Also in Frankreich ist dieses Jahr ja das Linux-Desktop, so wie es aussieht.
Pipeline all belong to foreign vendors like Microsoft, then your state does not fully
control its own computing environment.
So on April 8th, 2026, Francis Deneux, which is kind of like the government's central
IT agency, formally announced that the French state is moving away from Windows towards
Linux desktops as part of...
Dann schau ma ma, wie lang sie das machen.
Ich hoffe ja, das klappt.
Jetzt, wo es Euro Office gibt oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Ob das was wird, sei mal auch dahingestellt, weil ganz im Ernst, so bei so digitalen Projekten, sei es jetzt in Deutschland oder in der EU, habe ich ja immer kein so gutes Gefühl, dass sie das auf die Reihe kriegen.
Aber sie können ja weiterhin Office im Browser verwenden.
Migration Plan by Autumn of 2026, covering desktops, collaboration tools, antivirus, AI,
databases, virtualization and network equipment. So they're not just casually switching over to Linux,
they're really looking to have a fully independent software stack that they can control themselves.
And this pursuit of digital sovereignty is not a new thing for France. They've actually been
working on this for decades.
So in 2005,
the National Gendarmerie, which is
kind of like... Das ist die Polizei quasi.
...a federal police
slash military force started
replacing Microsoft Office
with OpenOffice and they made
the Open Document Format or
.odf the national standard
for office documents.
Then in 2008, that
same department started migrating
towards a customized
Ubuntu...
2008 schon.
Die sind aber eben schnell gewesen, die Franzosen.
John Buntu.
Also ich bin eigentlich dafür, die sollten zu einem richtig ordentlichen Ubuntu switchen.
Zum Beispiel zu
Mobuntu.
Das ist der einzig wahre
Ubuntu-Skin, oder?
Mobuntu.
How to Mobuntu.
Wir haben uns das sogar schon mal
just for fun im Stream installiert.
Wie ich das fand,
Niri fand ich ganz gut.
Wir haben es ja noch nicht fertig eingerichtet.
Wir haben ja wirklich nur installiert
ein bisschen in der Niri-Config.
Jetzt brauchen wir einen Launcher,
jetzt brauchen wir eine Shell.
Das müssen wir alles noch machen.
Ich mag es, wie du solche Sachen immer griffbereit hast.
Sowas wie Mobuntu.
Ah ja, 20 Jahre Linux-Erfahrung.
Irgendwo muss sich der Senior-Engineer ja hier auszeichnen.
Der weiß, was Mobuntu ist.
Kann ich bestimmt auf der Arbeit auch mal glänzen mit.
Ich habe letztens gesehen, dass wir auf Testkisten Firefox installiert haben, auf Testservern.
Weil irgendein Scanner angesprungen ist.
Das passiert, wenn du Entwicklern Rootrechte auf Testservern gibst.
Hast du Firefox drauf?
Finde ich jetzt aber nicht schlimm, sind Testkisten.
Ich frage mich nur, was die damit treiben mit Firefox auf der Kiste.
Ob die sich das X vorworten und dann irgendwas browsen mit oder so?
Keine Ahnung.
Warte mal, wir müssen erst mal gucken hier.
zu Ubuntu-based Distros
was saving the National Police Force
2 million euros per year
in licensing fees
and maintenance costs
and those savings have likely increased
in the years following
because by June of
Ja, dann ist wieder was anderes.
Ich hab gedacht, jetzt so Frankreichweit.
Ja.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
So was musst du wirklich langsam machen, dass die Leute sich dran gewöhnen können.
Sonst ist also der Backlash viel zu groß.
ist wahrscheinlich ein ganz aufgrundsätzliches, lokales Unterstützungsteam
und wird für die End-Users in der Hand entwickelt,
anstatt dass eine große amerikanische Technik-Familie sie einfach auf sie fordert.
Die User können endlich die Software kontrollieren.
Moment, hatten wir da nicht auch eine Mode für das?
Bitte erlaubt mir, einen Moment zu unterbrechen.
... die Software kontrollieren die User.
Und was wirklich interessant ist, ist, dass Franz nicht nur ein Ein-Hit-Wunder mit Jinbuntu ist,
Die Franzosen wollen es aber echt wissen, wenn die jetzt sogar mit NixOS um die Ecke kommen, Alter.
Ich finde das eigentlich mega nice.
Besser als diese ganzen Nextcloud-Aufgüsse da.
Das taugt bestimmt mehr. Ich hoffe, es ist nicht nur eine Nextcloud-Skin.
Wahrscheinlich funktioniert das besser als Nextcloud.
Okay, ich tue, ganz ehrlich, ich tue Nextcloud wahrscheinlich unrecht.
Vielleicht ist das in den letzten Jahren viel besser geworden.
NixOS hast du nicht verstanden. Also, ich habe NixOS auch noch nie verwendet.
Ich weiß aber glaube ich so ungefähr was NixOS auszeichnet und zwar, dass es ein Immutable System ist. Das heißt du hast eine Config Datei, wo du drinnen reinschreibst zum Beispiel diese und diese Packages sollen installiert sein und im Heimatverzeichnis soll diese Datei mit diesem Inhalt eingelegt werden.
So, da hast du eine große Config-Datei und das war's.
Das ist die einzige Datei quasi, die sich ändert.
Wenn du neues NixOS brauchst, nimmst du diese eine Config-Datei und hast exakt das gleiche System widerstehend.
Der Rest ist immutable.
So, das ist so, wie ich es verstanden habe, der Seller.
So, das Aushängeding von NixOS.
Es gibt auch noch, neben NixOS gibt es noch Nix an sich, das ist der Package Manager.
Der greift quasi auf das Repo von Nix Packages zu.
Den kannst du überall verwenden.
NixOS ist quasi das komplette Betriebssystem im YouTube.
Nix an sich ist ziemlich nice als Package Manager, weil die haben halt alles.
Ja, das ist zum Beispiel auch ganz gut für Docker-Files, um da, wenn man irgendwas braucht mit Paketen drin, das kann man mit Nix da drin in der Docker-Image reinpacken. Da musst du keine Software-Pakete irgendwie selbst bauen und sowas. Also, ja, es ist gut, dass es das gibt.
ich persönlich habe jetzt für mich noch nicht so diesen riesen seller da verkaufs argument damit
bekommen warum ich nix us verwenden sollte aber die franzosen die sind da anscheinend voll dabei
das richtige nass jetzt gefunden wie ging es die letzten 14 tagen nicht gut ich habe nicht
mal weitergebaut visio which is a video conferencing platform which officially
Ich muss sagen, irgendwie mag ich das Interface-Design von denen.
Das ist wirklich schön klar lesbar.
Genau die richtige Größe, das gefällt mir.
Das ist quasi das französische Excel.
So, hier ist das zu sehen, aufgeschlüsselt, was die verwenden.
Können wir das vielleicht übersetzen?
in Deutsch, da kann man es in Englisch übersetzen,
ähm,
La Suite,
Le, Le, Le Suite,
oder wie auch immer.
Ja, und,
so um uns, ich sehe das ähnlich,
Office 365
hat halt auch saumäßig
viel drin, das alles
nachzubauen, ja, auch diese
Geschichte mit, mehrere Leute können das
bearbeiten, Versionshistorie,
die ganzen seit
Jahrzehnten Office-Programme am Start,
das ist echt nicht so easy.
Dann hast du noch einen Drive mit dabei.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der große
Office-User, ja, ich kenn davon die
meisten Sachen wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Dann hast du ja auch bei Office, hast du ja auch so Dinger
dabei, um irgendwelche Workflows zu automatisieren
und sonst was, da gibt es ja total viel
Krempel.
Und wenn du wirklich eine Firma hast,
die da richtig invested ist,
so richtig deep in diesem Office
oder sorry, nicht Office,
Microsoft 365
Copilot
App.
Nee, war es ja dann doch nicht.
Dann ist es schwierig, da auszusteigen.
Okay.
Meet.
Source Code Meet.
Ja, okay, das
sind keine irgendwelche komischen
Nextcloud-Fox oder so, sondern das
machen die selbst.
Und written in
TypeScript und Python.
Warum nicht?
Source.
Ja, Freunde, jetzt JavaScript Backend.
Python.
ZFS und Spindown ist ne dumme Kombi
Ne warum
Kannst du machen
Es gab aber letztens einen Bug
In den wir auch reingelaufen sind
Dass es nicht richtig funktioniert
Da musstest du ne spezielle Option setzen
Weil sonst alle 10 Minuten dein ZFS aufgewacht ist
Ansonsten kannst du ZFS und Spindown machen
Das ist kein Problem
in einem der neueren Versionen ist das dann auch gefixt, dieser Bug mit dem Spindown.
Oder hast du dieses Problem, dass das alle 10 Minuten aufwacht?
Oder warum fragst du?
Da kann ich dir zeigen, woran das liegt.
Wenn ich es noch finde.
Gucken wir erstmal hier.
Das Video fertig.
Das Ding ist halt auch, es ist auch echt schwierig, so aus Unternehmen rauszukriegen.
Ich sehe das bei mir auf der Arbeit. Wir haben ja Outlook, wie gefühlt jedes Unternehmen.
Okay, manche hatten früher noch Notes, aber die meisten haben Outlook und Exchange.
und wir haben halt eigene Outlook-Plugins,
die nur für die Firma entwickelt wurden und benutzt werden.
Ja, zum Beispiel irgend so ein komisches Raumplanungs-Plugin und so,
was ein reines Outlook-Plugin ist.
So ganz merkwürdig, das kriegst du halt dann nicht wieder raus.
Das macht übrigens überhaupt keinen Sinn, ja.
Also man könnte sowas easy mit einem Webinterface machen,
aber das ist halt so tief, hat sich das jetzt über 30 Jahre,
hat sich das so tief
eingenistet, in allen, oder
40 Jahre, hast du schon, in Unternehmen,
dass es echt schwierig ist, das rauszukriegen.
Du hast das Problem
mit dem Spindown. Welches Problem?
Dass das alle 10 Minuten aufwacht?
Chat
ZFS. Wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal,
ob, ups, oh nein, jetzt hab ich verkackt.
Wir gucken mal, ob wir das finden.
Was?
Das neue Outlook unterstützt ja die alten Plugins nicht.
Deswegen gibt es bei uns auch noch kein neues Outlook.
Der LS...
Dein HBA spinnt.
SAS Host is non-operational.
Der hat wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Probleme.
Ja, dann...
Keine Ahnung.
Also alle 10 Minuten.
Warte mal, hier müssen wir kurz gucken
ZFS
Hier
Das da ist es doch
Ich hab's ja sogar gebuckmarkt
TXG Timestamp
DB Sync
If idle costs unnecessary disk access
Prevent spin down
Hier, das ist das
So, du kannst das beheben
Indem du
Irgendwas setzt
hier, indem du das da setzt,
das kannst du ja auch mal mit dem Modprobe
ausprobieren.
Hier.
Mach das da mal.
Mach das da.
Und
sag mir
dann mal Bescheid, ob es bei dir die Sache
auch gefixt hat. Bei mir hat es das gefixt.
Die sind alle 10 Minuten aufwachen.
Ähm,
Mittlerweile ist das ja gefixt in den neueren ZFS-Versionen.
Ich kann den Link nicht schicken, weil ich hier auf meiner Linienkiste bin und ich keine Sachen rauskopieren kann, sondern nur reinkopieren.
Guck, geht nicht.
Ich kann keine Links schicken.
Aber ich kann hier Links schicken.
Issue ZFS XTG oder wie hieß das Ding?
TGX?
Ja, das da.
in welchem Kontext, ich hab's auf Proxmox,
auf meinem NAS,
das mehr als nur
NAS macht, das Netzwerk Storage macht und
auch Home Assistant und sowas.
Wobei, ha, noch macht's das nicht,
ja, was es machen soll.
Mundterror, sag mir mal, ob's bei dir was
gebracht hat.
So, mit welcher
ZFS-Version
ist das jetzt gefixt?
Okay.
Also man braucht ZFS 2.4.1 anscheinend.
Ja gut.
Ist halt so.
Muss man ein bisschen warten.
Wir haben uns Trunas angeguckt im Stream.
Vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit, glaube ich sogar.
Vielleicht hat Trunas das ja schon ge-cherrypicked, diesen Fix.
Backported. Kann doch sein.
Die sind ja immer schnell bei sowas.
wir haben doch hier irgendwo
TrueNAS
ausprobiert.
Hier.
Mit TrueNAS.
Da haben wir mal TrueNAS ausprobiert.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, so krass
gefeiert hab ich's jetzt nicht.
Also, für reines
Netzwerk
Storage ist das glaube ich
echt nett verkehrt.
Aber der
Container, VM
und
Docker Part hat mir nicht gefallen.
Xenpai, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Op Media Vault finde ich nice.
Op Media Vault werde ich verwenden
für meine Storage-Anforderungen.
Allerdings in der VM
unter Proxmox.
Bleichi, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich habe mir die Hälfte übersehen.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Creator Dashboard.
Splexe auch schon gesubbt.
Delur.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Dankeschön für die Subs, Leute.
Pog-Subscription.
Massive.
Pogu.
So.
Dann gucken wir das Video doch mal fertig.
Was machen die Franzosen denn noch?
business owner in you have the option to choose between microsoft google zoom or
your own government software stack japaner genugau mit der last option
da wäre ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher was er hier meiner meinung nach außen
außer aus dem blick lässt ist diese die sachen von microsoft und google die
kommen es ist service da musst du nicht selbst betreiben für diese office oder
beziehungsweise für diesen diesen invest mal ab stack da von frankreich da
braucht sie ja garantiert einen server auf dem du das installiert das werden
die ja nicht erst service anbieten und da fällt es bei vielen halt schon
raus die nehmen fix und fertig ja wenn die die auswahl haben ich schließe ein
abo für microsoft 365 office co pilots app ab oder ich muss mich um server
Hosting kümmern und da drauf
den Gram installieren und mich drum kümmern,
da ist halt
die Frage
nicht...
Der Ausschlag geht dann eher Richtung
Microsoft für viele.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
das war aber Zufall, dass der kaputt gegangen ist,
während du mal den Spindown getestet hast.
Dein Controller
wird nicht verreckt sein,
durch den Spindown.
Das wird Zufall sein. Manchmal gibt es dumme Zufälle. Das ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis jemand das Hausding anbietet. Ja und dann ist halt wieder der Frage, wenn das so eine 3-Mann-Klitsche ist oder eine 20-Mann-Klitsche, trauen die denen ähnliche Sachen zu wie Microsoft?
Weil gerade wenn du, ich kann es euch nur sagen, wenn man in der Finanzbranche unterwegs ist, da ist auch unglaublich wichtig, dass die Erfahrung haben im Umgang mit der Finanzbranche. Also sprich, wie es dort mit irgendwelchen Auditsachen aussieht und Regularien und sonst was. Und Microsoft und Google kann das halt.
und ob das die 20-Mann-Klitsche das kann, weiß man halt nicht, ja, beziehungsweise ob die das kann, vielleicht, aber ob die das garantieren kann, nachweislich, ist dann auch wieder die Frage, also das, es ist nicht damit getan, dass es ein Softwareprodukt auf GitHub gibt, selbst wenn es Feature Complete mit Microsoft wäre, also Feature Parity hätte.
Ja, genau.
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß, wie das Ding aussieht.
Ist das on board bei dir oder ist das eine extra Karte?
weil ich hatte mal
ein
ich hatte mal daheim so ein Ding
von S-Rock Rack
hieß das Ding
und das hatte hier so ein passiv gekühltes
hier, das war dann
quasi der HBA, also nach dem Motto
hier irgendwas, war da so ein
einfach so ein Block drauf, APC-Karte
und das Ding wurde auch
unglaublich heiß
Da hättest du Eier draufbraten können.
Also das ist die einzige Kiste, wo ich mal meine Hand draufgelegt habe.
Normalerweise im Rechenzentrum, die Server, da habe ich nie die Hand draufgelegt, während die an war.
Da fehlt welche Sachen.
Ich würde gerne öfters mal ins Rechenzentrum.
Ich sage es ja ganz oft.
ich vermisse die Zeiten, wo ich
regelmäßig täglich da
Turnschuh-Admin gemacht hab,
Zeug eingebaut hab. Ich meine, ich vermisse
das zu zweit
Playcenter einbauen, vermisse ich
kein Stück.
Aber irgendwie war es trotzdem cool.
Und ich hab gehört von unseren
Azubis, das ist ja mittlerweile,
ich weiß, das ist jetzt wieder Opa Max erzählt
was vom Krieg, ja, aber
mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass
unsere Azubis, wenn die
in dem Team sind, was tatsächlich
regelmäßig auch ins Rechenzentrum geht,
also die machen ja so eine Rotation, die gehen ja überall mal hin,
die haben da mittlerweile eine elektronische
Hebebühne für Server
und einen Akkuschrauber.
WTF?
Was wir früher
hatten, war
einen Bollerwagen, da wurden die Server
drauf geschmissen und rüber
ins Rechenzentrum gekarrt.
Dann hat einer den Server
gehalten, beziehungsweise man hat
die Schienen da reingefummelt
rausgezogen.
Man hat den da rein
gehievt.
Oder Switche.
Switche war ganz schlimm.
An die Switche,
warte mal,
dass ich euch das mal zeigen kann.
Ja, diese Dinger.
Switche waren ganz schlimm.
Da bist du hin, hast die Dinger
ans Rack gehalten mit einer Hand.
Hand drunter und die großen
Switche sind ja auch noch größer und schwerer
Die hast du
Du hast so einen großen hier
So ein großes fettes
So eins nicht, so ein ganz normaler
48 Port so
Ja
So ein Ding hast du dann
Hast du auf einer Hand
Gehalten ins Rack
Auf der Seite
da hattest du diese Dinger, hast es
ins Rack gehalten, die ist so
auf Kopfhöhe, dir ist es
halb abgefallen, der Arm,
und dann hast du versucht, mit einem
Schraubendreher hier neben, diese Dinger,
vorher hast du noch diese Käfigmuttern
da reingeklipst und in den Finger eingeklemmt,
und da hast du
echt Muskelkater im Arm gehabt danach.
Oder zu zweit
Playcenter einbauen.
Baut mal so ein fettes Ding zu zweit
ein, das sind mindestens 8 HE.
Ja, und mittlerweile gibt es Hebebühnen und Akkuschrauber.
Ich kann das aber verstehen.
Ich würde das auch lieber mit dem Akkuschrauber und der Hebebühne machen.
Ich sage nur, wir haben das damals nicht mit dem Akkuschrauber und der Hebebühne gemacht.
Server Shifter nennt sich das.
Aha, Moment.
Server Shifter.
Shifter.
Heißt das wirklich so?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein
Gangschalt-Dings, Schalthebel.
Data Center
vielleicht noch suchen dabei.
Die wiegen unbestückt keine
130 Kilo. Also 130 Kilo
kann man nicht vorstellen, dass die gewogen haben.
Also wie man das gemacht hat, man hat erst die Schienen ins Rack eingebaut und dann hat man zu zweit das Playcenter reingehoben und dann bestückt.
Ne, das nicht. Aber was es gibt, was ich auch witzig finde, ist hier Server Throwing Championship. Serverweitwurf.
Serverweitwurf.
Opa.
Es gibt eine Competition.
Serverweitwurf.
Was sich alles gibt, oder Leute?
Oh.
Die Server-Weitwurf-Competition.
Championship.
Okay, zack.
Komm, wir haben jetzt genug geguckt, was die Franzosen treiben.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch hier an.
Every Killed of Windows Feature Explained in 9 Minutes.
Ich bezweifle, dass es Every Feature sein wird.
Und mal gucken, ob wir uns an die meisten Sachen noch erinnern.
Was? Wie hieß das Ding?
Windows to go?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Das gab's?
By the way, seit ich mein Kabel gefixt habe,
ist das Übersteuern weg.
Weil sonst hättet ihr wahrscheinlich schon was gesagt.
Ja, oder? Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder gut.
Yep.
Nope.
education editions it essentially allowed users to carry their entire desktop environment in
specially made usbs and this wasn't a clunky feature by any means with how intelligently it
handled portability on first boot it would detect the host machine and install the necessary drivers
then behave like a normal system on subsequent launches it also included strict security
features removing the usb would freeze the system immediately followed by shutdown and internal
drives on the host machine could be hidden to prevent data leakage as it was built for
enterprise great use after all but despite this innovation windows to go was discontinued
in 2019 and removed entirely
in 2020. It didn't support modern
Windows feature updates, meaning full reinstalls
were required just to stay current.
The certified USB drive, as this feature depended
on, became scarce and performance varied
significantly compared to...
Hast du gut geschätzt? Okay, zeig mal.
Ähm.
Kostet?
Ja gut, aber voll bestückt.
Voll bestückt. Guck mal.
Da ist ja alles drin.
Schon.
Oder?
Nee, oder?
Oder nicht?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir 100 Kilo da gehoben haben.
Wobei, 100 Kilo mit zwei Leuten geht, aber ist anstrengend.
Nee, egal.
Oh ne, er erinnert sich, ich erinnere mich noch dran.
Hi, I'm Cortana.
Oh ne, please.
Niemand, niemand vermisst es, oder?
Niemand vermisst es.
Damals, damals
war Microsoft noch nicht so auf diesem
AI-Hype. Heute
würde das Ding auch nicht Cortana heißen,
sondern Copilot Voice Assistant oder sowas.
Und sowas haben wir ja mittlerweile wieder
in Windows drin.
Übrigens, an sich,
also ich fand den Namen sehr nice.
Cortana ist die
KI aus Halo.
und das fand ich cool, dass das so heißt.
Aber das war es auch schon.
Das war es auch schon, was ich daran cool fand.
Ja, dass du das cool fandst, kann ich mir vorstellen bei dem Namen.
Das war die Microsoft-Konkurrenz zu Siri.
Oh ne.
Windows Phone, Alter.
Wir hatten bei mir auf der alten Arbeit einen,
der war fest davon überzeugt,
dass Windows Phones die Zukunft sind.
Der hat gesagt,
in 10 Jahren haben alle Windows Phones,
es gibt kein iPhone und Android mehr.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Kennt ihr noch Samsung Sam?
Stimmt, das gab es ja auch noch.
Ich habe von Samsung Sam nie was gehört,
Das hat initial mal Schlagzeilen gemacht, weil das so einen Disney-Character-Style-mäßig hatte, Avatar.
Und danach hat nie wieder einer davon gesprochen.
Da haben die ja riesen Tamtam drum gemacht.
Kassau hat es interessiert.
Es gab auch immer noch hier Paint.
Paint 3D gab es mal eine Zeit lang.
Hier.
Das war die Zeit, wo alle gesagt haben,
VR dieses Mal, dieses Mal
wird VR voll einschlagen.
Die letzten fünf Mal nicht, aber dieses Mal.
Das ist aber auch schon wieder abgeappt.
Sogar Apple
hat da Probleme
mit ihrer Apple Vision
Pro,
wo sie jetzt quasi ein bisschen
Entwicklergerät zwei Jahre im Umlauf hatten
und immer noch nichts in Aussicht ist.
Also, ja.
Naja.
such as microsoft hololens auch die google hatte doch auch so ein ding also
nicht nicht so vorab google google class hatten die doch mal eine zeit lang wo man
vermutet hat dass google class eigentlich nur released wurde bzw
weiterentwickelt wurde weil die google class chefin was mit dem google chef
mit dem Google Gründer hatte, gab es doch so Gerüchte damals.
Ja, auch diese Apple-4R-Geschichte hat
struggled, Traction zu kriegen.
...
Also, daran kann ich mich gar nicht mehr erinnern.
Und was war jetzt? Habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Das Taskbar, auch bekannt als My People, wurde 2017...
Da kann ich mich dunkel noch dran erinnern.
Das habe ich nie benutzt und habe mich gefragt, was wollen die eigentlich von mir?
Habe ich bis heute nicht gecheckt, was das eigentlich sein sollte.
...17 ist Teil des Windows 10 Fall Creators Updates.
Statt Apps zu öffnen, um zu kommunizieren,
könnt ihr eure Lieblingskontakte direkt an die Taskbar öffnen und mit ihnen interagieren.
Klicken auf eine Kontakt, öffnet die kompakte Interface,
where you could send messages, view recent conversations and quickly share files.
It integrated with services like Outlook and Skype,
with limited support for some other third-party apps.
But what killed this feature was that it just didn't really solve anything.
Firstly, support was quite limited, even within Microsoft's own ecosystem,
and major apps like WhatsApp or Discord weren't integrated at all.
More importantly, it took up valuable taskbar space, which ironically...
War das nicht so, dass es zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch zwei Teams-Versionen gab?
So dieses Windows Teams und das richtige Teams? Wobei, ist das immer noch so, Chat? Oder gibt es mittlerweile nur noch ein Teams?
Ich weiß gar nicht, beides nannte sich auch Teams. Das eine ließ sich da integrieren, das andere nicht. Irgendwie so war das doch.
in modernen Windows-Versionen überhaupt.
Gab's da noch schon Teams?
Ha, gute Frage.
Nee, Skype und Teams gab's eine Weile parallel.
Windows Media Center was one of my...
Das war geil, Windows Media Center!
Das war richtig nice, das hab ich sogar eine Weile verwendet,
im Wohnzimmer, in der alten Wohnung.
Da hatte ich so ein von Shuttle, so ein Mini-PC am Fernseher angeschlossen damals.
Das war noch ein CRT-Fernseher, so alt war das.
Da hatte ich Windows Media Center drauf, das war richtig gut.
Das war gar nicht schlecht.
Das hat auch ein nettes Interface. Also ich fand das echt gut.
Ich habe die Videos erwähnt, aber MediaCentral war für fast alle Medien, wie Musik, Fotos, DVDs und sogar frühere Streaming-Services wie Netflix, alle in einer App.
You could even use devices like the Xbox 360 to stream that media from your PC to a TV.
But of course, because this required specialized hardware, which most didn't have at the time,
it remained a bit niche, and development largely stopped after Windows 7.
Especially as streaming platforms replaced traditional TV and DVDs,
its core purpose just sort of disappeared.
And by Windows 10, the media center was completely removed.
WordPad was one of the longest-lasting...
Ja, das braucht man auch nicht mehr.
Aber, also, so was ähnliches, ich benutze ja heute noch Kodi zum Fernsehen.
gucken allerdings etwas besser als damals mit windows media center damals
hatte ich so einen dvb tuner an meiner an meinem mini pc oder mini pc war das
in diesem bär bauen pc im wohnzimmer dran mit media center das ist das haben
wir schon rumgepackt ich habe ich kann euch das mal zeigen
ok ich habe keine ahnung was das ding von der ip hat ehrlich gesagt
Ich habe so ein Ding hier, das hat einen 8-fach DVB-C-Tuner drin.
Darauf habe ich Custom Firmware installiert und da habe ich TV Headend laufen.
Und das streamt über das Netzwerk quasi dann TV Headend an meinen Kodi auf dem Shield TV.
So ist das Setup.
Und das Funst, echt nicht schlecht.
Und das Schöne ist, ich kann mich auf meinen DVB-C-Tuner einloggen per SSH. Also für Fernsehen ist das top. Was damit natürlich nicht geht, ist diese ganzen Dinger mit privaten Fernsehsendern in HD mit Smartcard und so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wer das mitmacht, dem ist eh nicht mehr zu helfen. Seriously. Das ist so ein absoluter Bullshit. Man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wenn du private Sender gucken möchtest in HD, dann brauchst du ein offizielles Gerät von denen mit einer offiziellen Smartcard, also von deinem Provider, die das unterstützen.
Du musst dafür Geld bezahlen, du musst ein Abo abschließen, dass du private Sender in HD gucken kannst. Du brauchst ein Abo, also brauchst ein offizielles Gerät, ein Abo und dann können die dir trotzdem verbieten, weil das nur mit offiziellen Geräten in Kombination mit einer Smartcard geht.
Du bezahlst Geld dafür, dass du, meinetwegen sagen wir jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, ProSieben in HD gucken kannst. Und dann können die dir verbieten, Sendungen aufzunehmen oder aber das Spulen in aufgenommenen Sendungen verbieten.
Also du bezahlst mehrfach an mehreren Stellen Geld dafür, lässt dich ultra gängeln und dann musst du dir auch noch die Werbung angucken. Also wer das macht, der ist einfach nur dumm. Der ist richtig dumm.
Wenn ich irgendwelches private Zeug in HD gucken will, würde, wollen würde, dann würde ich mir das über die Join-App angucken oder sowas, ja?
Aber doch im Leben nicht so, übers Fernsehen, über DVB-C, mit Karte, mit verboten zum Spulen, niemals, nie, auf gar keinen Fall.
Also wer das macht, ist richtig dumm.
Das geht damit natürlich nicht, ja?
Ja, man kann irgendwie hier tricksen, das geht natürlich.
Es gibt ja Möglichkeiten, um das zu umgehen.
Das funktioniert mal schlecht, mal recht mit der jeweiligen Smartcard-Version, mit sonst was.
Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so easy, wie man das, wie sich das jetzt liest, ja.
Du brauchst dann irgendeinen Smartcard-Emulator, irgendein Karte-Lesegerät
und dann musst du hier und da, das ist, du brauchst erstmal eine Smartcard überhaupt, ja.
Das ist in der Tat gar nicht so einfach.
Wenn du ein offizielles Gerät verwendest,
dann greifen diese ganzen DRM-Sachen,
also dass sie dir Aufnahmen verbieten können,
beziehungsweise das Spulen verbieten können in deiner Aufnahme,
wenn du sie dann anguckst.
Deswegen brauchst du ja offizielles Smartcard, offizielles Gerät,
dass sie dir das verbieten können.
Also wer das macht, ist einfach nur dumm.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Und bei Windows 10, der Medienzentrum wurde komplett entfernt.
WordPad war einer der längsten...
bräuchte es irgendwas, was das wirklich abspielt
während der Aufnahme und dann capturet.
Aber dann hast du ja immer noch HDCP
dazwischen,
wo du dann nicht so einfach capturen kannst.
Also das ist generell
so Fernseh,
so dieses klassische Fernseh,
was über DVB-T, DVB-C,
DVB-S geht, das ist von der Technik her
extrem krasser Abfuck.
Das ist einfach nur Kacke.
Deswegen, das einzige, was ich im Fernsehen gucke, noch gucke, sind irgendwelche Dokus oder so. Und das gucke ich aber auch übers Mediacenter. Der Grund, warum ich dieses Ding hier mit dem klassischen DVB-C-Tuner überhaupt noch habe, ist, weil meine Mutter halt gerne Fernsehen aufnimmt.
Die ist das nicht anders gewöhnt.
Die kommt mit den Apps nicht klar.
Die brauchen Knopf, wo drauf steht.
Also bei mir ist im Wohnzimmer, ist auf dem Shield TV,
ist einfach, also was heißt bei mir,
das ist eigentlich für meine Mutter,
die guckt dann auf dem Shield TV,
hat die Kodi offen im Fullscreen,
kann dann auswählen, wie klassisch auf dem Fernseher,
erstes Programm, zweites Programm und sonst was.
und dann streamt das hier von der Box
an Shield TV. Das ist
für die easy und die benutzt
das halt gerne mit
Programmieren im Fernsehen
und die hat ja auch noch so eine komische Fernsehzeitung,
wo sie dann immer guckt. Ah,
das könnten wir uns jetzt programmieren. Ganz ehrlich,
whatever.
Leaked!
Fuck, Alter. Aber das ist
eigentlich, hab ich schon oft genug erzählt,
wie das ist bei uns.
Ja.
man kann sich jetzt drüber schreiten, wer bei wem wohnt,
aber streng genommen wohne ich bei meiner Mutter, weil die das Haus
geerbt hat.
Ich erb das
irgendwann mal,
aber noch gehört es meiner Mutter.
Wir wohnen beide, das ist das alte Haus vom Opa.
Ja, und also
die
stehen halt so auf klassisches Fernsehen, ja,
die nimmt sich dann rosamunde Pilcher oder irgendwie
sowas auf.
Und dafür habe ich dieses Ding hier.
Aber ansonsten, ich hätte kein, also, würde die das nicht brauchen?
Ich hätte keinen DVB-C-Tuner mehr.
Was ich gucke, ist online, fertig.
Was nicht online ist, existiert für mich nicht.
Ganz einfach.
Jetzt müssen wir das gerade noch mal fertig gucken, das Video.
Und dann muss ich runtergehen, was fordern.
Kannst du einen NAS-Home-Server empfehlen?
Ja.
Wobei, nehm das mal mit einer Prise Skepsis.
weil ich selbst noch nicht damit im Lauf, zum Laufen, also noch nicht im Daily,
als Daily Driver nennt man es doch so schön, verwende.
Es gibt zwei Nasses, die ich eigentlich ganz nice finde.
Oder eigentlich noch mehr, aber nur zwei davon habe ich ausprobiert.
Das da finde ich gut. Das ist auch preis-leistungsmäßig echt ganz okay.
was da mega nice ist, du bekommst
3 SSD Slots
also 3 NVMe SSD Slots
5 Festplatten Base
ähm, Onboard
10 Gig, wobei
die 10 Gig Netzwerkkarte
das ist der
Schwachpunkt von dem Ding
der Linux Treiber ist halt noch ein bisschen
äh, sackt noch ein bisschen
und du bekommst sogar ein PC Express
16 Fach Slot, also das Ding ist von der
von der Hardware ist das
Das ist das beste Preis-Leistungs-Milch, das beste Nass, was es gibt.
Das ist das mit der Garbage-Netzwerkkarte, beziehungsweise dem Garbage-Netzwerkkartentreiber.
Ansonsten von der Hardware ist das Ding top.
Du bekommst eine 8-Kern-CPU, die ordentliche Wumms hat und auch Single-Core-Performance gar nicht mal so schlecht ist.
Also das ist wirklich gut.
Ansonsten, was auch noch gut ist, Konkurrenzprodukt dazu.
Das da.
Das hat nur 4 Base und nur 2 leicht zugängliche NVMe Slots, aber es hat eine deutlich bessere Netzwerkkarte, die besser funktioniert mit dem Linux-Treiber und ein bisschen schwächere CPU.
Also die zwei Nasses finde ich persönlich ganz gut, wenn du was mittelgroßes haben willst. Für ganz kleine Sachen, so mit zwei Bays und so, gibt es noch anderes und für größere mit acht Bays gibt es nochmal anderes. Aber das ist glaube ich so der Sweet Spot für viele Leute. Die kann ich zumindest auf den ersten Blick gesehen empfehlen.
Was du dir angucken kannst, ein guter YouTube-Channel für Nass-Tests ist der hier. Der hat so gut wie alle Nasses, die es gibt, schon mal unter die Lupe genommen. Da kannst du dich inspirieren lassen von.
44 Terabyte, Alter
Jetzt hab ich mir erstmal eine 24 Terabyte
Geschuckt
Muss ich jetzt wieder was
Moment, Moment, Moment
WTF, Chat, Chat, Chat
Stellt euch mal vor, ich hab einen Raid
Mit 44 Terabyte Platten
Wie lange dauert denn dann
Ein Rebuild? Ne Woche?
Oder was?
Wie lange dauert
So ein Rebuild, Alter?
Machst du dann eine Woche rein und wartest auf die Rebuild oder was?
Ich verdiene nicht 9k netto.
Ich verdiene das einmal im Jahr, wenn ich Bonus-Auszahlung kriege.
Sonst mehr?
Nein.
Sonst ist es ja nur das normale Gehalt plus Rufbereitschaft.
Das war Rufbereitschaft, normales Gehalt plus Bonus.
Okay, es gibt jeden Monat ein bisschen Bonus,
aber die große Bonuszahlung gibt es immer im April.
Hast du eine Idee für einen VDSL-Router?
Keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich, Fritzbox regelt.
Fritzbox ist kein guter Router,
aber du willst wahrscheinlich auch keinen reinen Router,
sondern ein gutes Multifunktionsgerät.
Dafür ist die Fritzbox top.
Wenn du was suchst mit Modem, mit Telefonie-Funktionen und allem sowas, was man halt von der Fritzbox erwartet, ist das top.
Kann man nichts sagen. Fritzbox kannst du verwenden.
Wenn du jetzt auf spezielle Routing-Funktionen aus bist, ja, wie dass das irgendwie 10 Gig braucht und zwischen den Interfaces mit 1 Gig plus routen kann,
dass das OSPF kann oder sonstige Dinger.
Ja, dann oder irgendwie ein bisschen advanced Firewall regeln kann.
Dann ist eine Fritzbox nix, aber das will ja eigentlich daheim auch keiner.
Ich habe deswegen das so gemacht bei mir.
Ich habe die Kombination.
Ich habe eine Fritzbox.
Ich habe sogar drei Sachen.
Ich habe das Unity Media Modem.
Ich habe eine Fritzbox nochmal extra, weil ich zu faul bin bisher, das umzustellen.
Ich habe eine Fritzbox, die kann das, aber ich habe das bisher noch nicht umgestellt. Und dahinter habe ich einen MikroTik-Router. Ich habe noch einen relativ alten Hex-POE von MikroTik und der macht bei mir alles andere.
Hier sind die Access Points auch dran über PoE.
Und er hat fünf Ports.
Und an dem einen Port ist noch ein interner 10-Gig-Switch.
Aber für alles Routing-mäßige nehme ich das Ding.
Und das kostet auch nichts.
Das kostet 70 Euro oder so.
Aber man muss dazu sagen,
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist jetzt kein Einsteigergerät.
Also wenn man sich mal die Oberfläche anguckt von RouterOS,
da werdet ihr sehen...
Wie ist denn das jetzt? Demo? Demo? Oder wie war das?
Wie ist denn hier die...
RouterOS Demo Login...
Demo, Demo?
Admin, Admin ist es nicht.
Äh.
Ach, Left, Plank.
Oh Gott, Alter.
Da soll man erst mal drauf kommen.
Okay, einfach Login drücken.
Da hast du...
Oh, oh, das ist das neue Router-OS.
Du hast halt hier verdammt viel Zeug,
was du einstellen kannst, ja.
Also das ist wirklich...
Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Also wenn du da keinen Bock hast, dich mit auseinanderzusetzen oder auch keinerlei Background zu IT-mäßig, würde ich sie nicht unbedingt MikroTik-Router holen.
So, jetzt gucken wir das Video noch fertig.
in windows existiert von windows 95 in 1995 all the way to its removal in modern versions around
20 23 20 24 bei microsoft verstehe ich auch nicht dafür haben jetzt sicherheitslücken in
fucking notepad wir hatten letzten sicherheitslücken in notepad weil das aufgebaut haben weil wird per
deck ist capable den notepad but for more simpler than microsoft word in support rich text formatting
Und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum die WordPad entfernt haben. Ich meine, das war jetzt sicherlich nicht best ever, aber zum schnell mal was reinschreiben, ausdrucken, war das okay.
aber ich bin ja immer noch nach wie vor Markdown-Fan, ihr wisst ja, ich mache alles, was geht in Markdown, ich benutze keine Office-Produkte, außer, was ich ab und zu verwende, ist gezwungenermaßen Excel, aber das konsumiere ich nur, weil bei uns halt auf der Arbeit ganz viel über Excel-Tabellen läuft,
und was ich, das einzige Office-Produkt, was ich aktiv benutze, ist ab und zu mal PowerPoint,
so, weil die immer auf PowerPoint-Präsentationen stehen.
Ansonsten verwende ich nichts privat, gar nichts in Office und wenn ich was schreiben muss, dann Markdown.
WordPad ist seit Jahren unverändert.
Microsoft hat es offiziell im Jahr 2023 verabschiedet,
das bedeutet keine weiteren Updates oder Verbesserungen.
Der echte Warnpunkt kam aber im Jahr 2024,
als es von einer Version von Windows 11 entfernt wurde.
Bis 2026 existiert es nicht mehr in standarden Windows-Installationen,
mit keinem offiziellen Weg, es wieder zu installieren.
Die Gründe dafür, dass es entfernt wurde,
war nur, dass es Legacy-Software wurde,
mit niedriger Anwendung,
als bessere dritte-Partei-Apps herauskommen.
Aber es benötigte noch immer
Anwendungs- und Sicherheits-Updates.
Am gleichen Zeit,
passt es nicht mehr zu Microsofts Produktstrategie,
as the company wanted Notepad to be for basic text editing and Microsoft Word for advanced documents
and not have an awkward middle app.
Improvements to Notepad and Windows 11 also replaced some of WordPads' use cases,
which then led to its removal.
Homegroup was introduced in 2009 with Windows 7
as a way to make file and printer sharing across home PCs much simpler.
Before it existed, setting up network sharing required dealing with permissions, user accounts,
Ach nee, diese Geschichte, das habe ich nie verwendet.
Was habe ich nicht verwendet?
Wisst ihr, was es mir damals voll angetan hat unter Windows ME oder sowas?
Hier.
Internet Connection Sharing.
Internet
Connection Sharing.
Da konnte man
man konnte quasi
Nutt auf seiner Windows-Kiste machen
und damals habe ich mein Internet
verbindet, also ich hatte, damals war es so,
damals hatte man noch
altes DSL-Modem.
Man hat damals was richtig dummes
gemacht und zwar
diese Dinger hier
altes DSL-Modem.
Gibt es da einen
Wikipedia.
Ja, diese Dinger.
Leute, ihr könnt euch das in der heutigen Zeit
nicht vorstellen, aber
wisst ihr, wie man die Dinger damals
angeschlossen hat, die alten DSL-Modems?
Man hat die direkt an eine
Netzwerkkarte im Computer angeschlossen.
Also sprich, der Computer hing
mit einer, wo sich das überlegt,
Windows 98
hing mit Public
IP im Internet.
Ja?
Kann man sich nicht wirklich vorstellen, war aber damals so.
Was auch immer die Leute geritten hatten, das zu machen.
Aber das war damals so, da hattest du keinen Router davor.
Windows 98 hing Public mit der Public IP im Internet.
Du hattest damals da noch Zone Alarm.
Falls das noch jemand kennt.
Ja, Zone Alarm.
Zone Alarm als Firewall, dass dein Rechner nicht sofort von irgendwelchen Hackermans übernommen wurde.
Zone Alarm.
So, und damals habe ich dann Internet Connection Sharing gemacht
und habe im Endeffekt mein Windows PC in einen Router mit NAT verwandelt.
Und das sah dann...
Das sah dann so irgendwie aus, genau, Internet Connection Sharing.
Das fand ich richtig geil damals.
Da hab ich mich übelst Hackerman-mäßig gefühlt.
... could join instantly using that code.
Once connected, users could automatically share libraries like pictures, music, videos and documents,
along with printers, without manually configuring access rules.
It worked entirely on local networks, meaning no internet connection was required,
and included basic encryption tied to the shared passwords for security.
At the time, this solved the real problem.
Many households had multiple Windows PCs and...
Brauchst du dann zwei Netzwerkkarten?
Ja.
Brauchst du. Brauchst du. Eine für PPPoE und eine für internes Netzwerk. Ja, ja. Brauchst du zwei Netzwerkkarten.
Da damals auch BNC-Netzwerkkarten. Mit Terminator hinten dran.
... Storage was still limited, so Homegroup made those devices feel connected as a single system.
However, it was officially removed in Windows 10 in 2018...
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment. Analoge Modems waren per serielle Schnittstelle verbunden. DSL-Modems oder ADSL-Modems, besser gesagt, die waren per Netzwerk, RJ45-Kabel verbunden.
Du hast noch einen NTBA? Moment, ich denke, es gibt kein ISDN mehr.
Boah, was hast du da am Start, dass du noch ISDN hast?
NTBA, dann hast du auch noch einen Splitter davor.
Splitter, Alter.
way to share files. Homegroup was also limited to Windows devices and became redundant as other...
Gibt es noch ISDN bei der Telekom?
Ja.
Für Privatkonten ist die vollständige ISDN-Abschaltung
der Telekom seit 2019 für...
Siehste, gibt's nicht mehr.
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Ja, okay.
Wenn Businesskunden mit extra Vertrag und so,
dann verstehe ich das, ja.
das ist wieder was anderes, ja.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Okay.
So, Leute.
Jetzt
geh ich runter was essen. Ich hab mega
Hunger. Streamen
war wunderbar. Exzellent.
Geht schon gleich oder viel besser.
Ich muss
aufs Klo und ich muss was essen. Zwei Sachen,
die ich nicht während dem Stream erledigen
kann.
Dann hören wir uns. Bis denn. Vielleicht jetzt auch
nicht mehr mit so langer Pause. Macht's gut.
See you.